[Musique]
je suis un écrivain américain,
l'auteur du best-seller Lefleux
Phantom sur la France Ghost Fleet United
States qui a exploré
la guerre que les États-Unis pourraient avoir avec la Chine
dans les années 2020, plus récemment euh, à partir d'
aujourd'hui, j'ai un nouveau livre intitulé Control
qui va sortir, il est publié en
France sur la collision à venir avec l'
intelligence artificielle et la robotique. Je suis
obsédé par l'idée d'essayer de comprendre
quelle est la prochaine étape, quels sont les problèmes
vers lesquels la société se précipite et qu'elle
manque peut-être de ces grandes idées, de ces grands
conflits.  c'est quelque chose qui
est vraiment ce à quoi je me réveille chaque jour
en essayant d'y réfléchir davantage et
bien sûr d'utiliser la fiction pour comprendre que
j'ai la chance de travailler avec un
écrivain américain nommé Peter Singer, son
pseudonyme est pw singer et nous '  J'ai eu un
partenariat qui a environ
huit ans à ce stade et dans mon ancienne vie, j'étais
journaliste à Washington DC, à
Washington, excusez-moi au Wall
Street Journal
et il était une de mes sources lorsque j'écrivais
sur le secteur privé.  les entreprises militaires, les
questions de défense, les drones,
ses domaines d'expertise particuliers
et nous avons formé un partenariat à partir de cette
amitié une fois que j'ai quitté le journalisme et que je
l'ai laissé derrière moi il y a plus d'une douzaine d'années,
ce qui nous a amenés à travailler d'abord sur
la flotte fantôme et maintenant sur notre dernier livre
[  Musique]
[Musique]
c'est une super question et en 2022, c'est
sans doute l'un des moyens les plus importants
de débloquer un véritable aperçu de l'avenir,
en particulier de l'avenir des conflits,
ce que les écrivains et en particulier les écrivains
qui sont prêts à faire des recherches et
à écrire un avenir basé sur des faits.  la fiction peut faire,
c'est mieux comprendre
tout, depuis les
aspects des conflits futurs comme l'
équipe homme-machine, savoir si l'on peut faire confiance à un
robot, jusqu'à savoir si la Chine
est une nation capable de vaincre
les États-Unis, l'
une des meilleures choses que les écrivains puissent
faire en réfléchissant.  sur l'avenir, c'est parler
de choses dont personne ne veut
parler,
que le statu quo est souvent renforcé
par tout, des groupes de réflexion aux
rapports de recherche gouvernementaux, et ceux-ci
ont leur place, mais nous sommes à un moment
où nous devons être plus créatifs.  Je dois
penser l'impensable et trouver
des moyens de l'intégrer dans tout,
depuis la planification de la défense jusqu'à la stratégie, en passant par la
simple communication avec le public et l'
aider à comprendre ce qui se passe
dans le monde, car cela n'est souvent pas
fait. Il y a trop de gens qui
se parlent et les romans que je  J'ai
écrit avec Peter Singer, l'autre travail
que je fais consiste essentiellement à essayer de
comprendre ce qu'elle est.
Je pense que c'est une question d'incitations
et aussi
de médium lui-même. Vous savez, il y a l'
idée que le médium est le message que
pense Marshall.  manteau McClellan d'il y a
longtemps
si tout ce que vous êtes autorisé à faire est de créer
des briefs PowerPoint
dans un bureau du sous-sol du Pentagone,
il est très difficile d'introduire une
idée très perturbatrice que votre patron peut détester et que son
patron peut trouver inacceptable
et donc la question  alors si
vous travaillez dans une
organisation officielle, que ce soit dans la
communauté du renseignement ou dans un service militaire,
l'une de leurs branches,
quelle est la meilleure façon de sortir de
ce silo
et il n'y a rien de mieux qu'une histoire
pour le faire, les humains sont littéralement  câblés
comme des machines
pour comprendre une histoire pour partager une histoire,
qu'elle soit écrite ou parlée, cela
n'a pas d'importance mais fondamentalement, c'est
une entreprise très humaine
et la raison pour laquelle je pense qu'il est
également important de réfléchir à cette
approche de manière officielle
est que nous  Il y a tellement de
changements technologiques en ce moment,
qu'il s'agisse de l'essor de nouvelles formes d'
informatique comme l'informatique quantique, que ce soit
l'essor de drones plus sophistiqués et
autonomes, de la
guerre de l'information et cognitive,
quel que soit le sujet,
ce que nous oublions souvent et je vois des personnes
absentes de ces conversations
à la fois.  Le niveau officiel
est que nous allons tous vivre dans cet
avenir
et c'est un peu comme dans la
communauté du design lorsque vous essayez de
comprendre,
à partir d'une expérience utilisateur,
quel est le problème réel auquel quelqu'un est
confronté
et c'est vraiment à quel point un bon  L'écrivain
pense que je crois aussi quand ils adoptent
cette approche
[Musique],
ce sont vraiment tous ces éléments
ensemble, peut-être pas le dernier, car beaucoup de
gens nous disent que vous savez plus ou moins
quoi écrire, mais l'idée que
quand j'y pense  qu'est-ce qu'un gros
problème qui vaut la peine d'écrire un livre parce qu'un
livre prend des années et que vous
engagez vraiment beaucoup d'énergie émotionnelle
intellectuelle professionnelle, il y a un risque
et qu'il peut échouer, personne ne peut le lire
en fait avec le fantôme de Lefleut, cela aurait pu
être plus facile  pour nous d'avoir écrit
un livre de non-fiction qui aurait été
l'approche logique, rationnelle ou
linéaire,
mais l'enjeu de cette question sur laquelle nous
étions tombés
était que les États-Unis sous-estimaient la
montée militaire de la Chine et nous avons définitivement
conclu oui, encore
plus.  qu'il était très impopulaire en
2013 et 2014
d'en parler en public en Chine est une
menace
d'un point de vue analytique, mais
ce n'était pas une conversation largement acceptée
à Washington DC, du moins
c'est vrai dans le sens public, il y
avait un officier de la marine américaine  qui a été licencié à
l'époque pour avoir dit cela lors d'une
conférence professionnelle publique en 2000, je
crois 14.
et même si nous avions un pivot vers l'Asie,
même si nous avions cette idée que l'
Amérique devait se réorienter du centre et du Moyen-
Orient vers l'Asie-Pacifique, c'est  C'est
beaucoup plus difficile à faire que de déclarer une
politique, mais revenir à l'origine de
l'idée
lorsqu'il existe un large consensus autour d'un
concept dans ce cas, selon lequel la Chine
était une nation que les États-Unis pouvaient vaincre
la nation que la Chine n'avait pas.  maîtrisez
certaines technologies, vous ne seriez pas
vraiment en mesure d'obtenir une avance en matière d'IA ou de
furtivité des avions de sixième génération, peu importe
quand il y a un large consensus comme celui-là,
ma réponse immédiate est ce qui manque aux gens,
comme quel est l'angle mort, pourquoi
tout le monde veut-il croire cela  donc
quand tout le monde regarde de cette façon, mon
instinct est souvent de savoir ce qu'il y a là-bas,
une autre façon d'y penser est
simplement d'inverser les hypothèses selon lesquelles
les gens tiennent le plus à cœur.
Un autre exemple que nous avons exploré dans le
fantôme d'inondation dans la flotte fantôme était cette
notion de suprématie technologique.
et à quel point les États-Unis ont supposé à l'
époque qu'il s'agirait d'
une guerre mondiale au 21e siècle et d'un conflit mondial.
Nous avons donc commencé à déballer et à regarder
les choses d'un point de vue chinois. C'est un
peu cette équipe rouge dans le sens d'un jeu de guerre.
voyez
où, si vous ne jouez que votre propre camp, si vous
ne pensez qu'aux choses telles qu'elles vous ont
été enseignées, formées et
pour lesquelles vous êtes récompensé, vous risquez souvent de manquer
potentiellement la façon dont un adversaire
va exploiter ces
hypothèses.
un adversaire digne de ce
nom, comme on dit en anglais, que ce soit l'armée
chinoise, que ce soit le
renseignement russe, va examiner les
opportunités
et trouver exactement comment
il peut utiliser les forces de son
adversaire et les transformer en
faiblesse, donc cela faisait partie de la stratégie.  traiter un
autre aspect en ce sens que c'est un
roman un thriller techno thriller
mais il a des notes de fin il a
des centaines de notes de fin parce que nous voulions
être transparents avec nos lecteurs sur
ce que nous voyions,
que les preuves sont toutes là au
grand jour mais vous  Je dois en quelque sorte le mettre en
place
et nous avons utilisé un véhicule créatif pour en faire
un roman, mais ces notes de fin et
celles de l'histoire auraient très bien pu
être les mêmes notes de fin pour un livre de non-fiction.
J'ai eu des expériences vraiment intéressantes.
à Fort Benning en
Géorgie, je fais une conférence là-bas, nous avons un
centre américain où les officiers d'infanterie
sont formés, il y a une école aéroportée
et je faisais une visite des
installations de saut aéroporté et le
sergent-chef là-bas
me guide à travers le terrain
et  il me dit qu'il a dit que tu sais que le
livre est bon et j'étais comme si
tu l'avais aimé, il dit non, je veux dire, j'ai
regardé chaque note de bas de page,
je les ai toutes vérifiées, elles sont valables,
la raison pour laquelle je raconte cette histoire est que
il s'agit d'établir la crédibilité
auprès d'un lecteur militaire. Je suis un civil, je
suis un écrivain, je ne suis pas quelqu'un qui
a ces expériences, mais je
m'intéresse à ces mêmes questions et je
peux également utiliser ces notes de bas de page comme
moyen.  d'établir une sorte de bonne foi,
c'est-à-dire que nous avons fait le
travail acharné
et établi ces faits, puis nous
les avons mis dans le livre afin que le lecteur puisse
faire ses propres recherches et peut-être arriver à des
conclusions différentes,
c'est une facette importante  aussi, je pense que
lorsque vous écrivez sur l'avenir,
certaines personnes
pensent qu'elles doivent toujours avoir raison
quand il s'agit de penser à l'
avenir, elles veulent être la personne qui
prédit l'avenir et je ne sais pas
si c'est toujours possible
mais le fait de le faire, le processus
est vraiment très précieux parce que vous
pouvez alors, même si vous n'obtenez pas de
prédiction précise,
vous avez au moins, espérons-le, sorti
de vos hypothèses dans votre zone de confort
et réfléchi à certaines des plus risquées.  ou des
idées plus controversées qui
pourraient en fait refléter une réalité du
futur
[Musique]
euh,
je suis certain que
certaines parties de l'armée américaine
à l'époque, à la fin d'avant 2015,
2014, 2013, étaient très concentrées sur exactement
ce genre de choses.  des lions de mer de
communication
ceux que vous connaissez, les points d'étranglement d'accès aux ressources,
mais
l'un des plus grands défis lorsque l'on
réfléchit aux types de conflits
dont nous pensons que nous discutons est
qu'il se peut qu'une certaine partie de la
force,
même intellectuellement, comprenne les
problème,
mais si nos dirigeants politiques ne
prennent pas la question au sérieux et si le mandat n'est pas
donné pour accepter et reconnaître une menace
parce qu'elle déstabilise les
relations commerciales ou d'autres choses diplomatiques,
alors c'est une position très précaire d'
être stratégiquement au niveau national
parce qu'il y a  un
décalage entre les deux du
point de vue de la guerre et du
point de vue des plans de guerre, il existe bien sûr
des plans assez sophistiqués et complets pour toutes sortes d'
éventualités,
mais la différence est de pouvoir agir
en conséquence au niveau national bien avant qu'ils ne
soient nécessaires  et cela fait partie de ce que je
pense que nous essayons de faire avec ce
genre de projets, c'est de les utiliser pour
créer une prise de conscience, c'est-à-dire que
vous pouvez penser qu'une fatalité que vous
essayez d'éviter est dans
10 ans, peut-être 12 ou 13 ans,
mais vous  Je dois faire semblant
ou me préparer, je devrais dire
qu'il est beaucoup plus urgent que
cela se produise potentiellement beaucoup
plus tôt parce que nous ne contrôlons pas la vitesse à laquelle
nos adversaires avancent, que ce soit
leurs ambitions stratégiques, leur vision
de leur rôle dans le monde, la Russie est une
bonne  Un exemple de cela en ce moment avec l'
Ukraine
Xi Jinping en Chine est un très bon
exemple ainsi que sa transformation au cours
des quatre dernières années
pour articuler une vision qui ressemble beaucoup
plus à celle de Mao, tant au niveau national
qu'extérieur, je pense que la
réconciliation est difficile à faire et  donc nous
devons réfléchir à de nouvelles façons de le faire
[Musique]
le conflit
c'est une très grande question euh à un moment donné,
certainement euh,
tu sais, euh
au 911, j'étais à Chicago et je
travaillais dans le  Board of Trade Building en tant que
journaliste pour CBS Marketwatch à l'époque
et
je me souviens d'avoir regardé la télévision
que nous avions sur le
réseau américain d'information par câble appelé CNBC.
vous
le regardez toujours mais vous n'y prêtez pas vraiment
attention et en un instant,
vous avez vu
un flash de lumière auquel ils ont coupé
parce qu'ils s'étaient concentrés sur les
tours jumelles après que le premier
avion l'ait heurté, mais c'est le deuxième qui
était vraiment  le moment où vous avez réalisé
que tout avait changé parce qu'il y
avait un très faible éclair blanc
lorsque cet avion a heurté la deuxième tour
et puis, à mesure que l'image reculait,
les différents plans suivants vous
avez mieux compris ce qui se passait et
chaque américain a un moment
où il peut  réfléchissez à ce qui a
suivi dans les semaines qui ont suivi ce sentiment
d'engourdissement et de choc.
Je pense que la réponse militaire en
Afghanistan était un reflet naturel et correct
de ce droit d'essayer de
poursuivre les personnes qui ont perpétué la
menace
quand on attend avec impatience l'invasion de l'
Irak.
et sur le
plan politique, l'une des
choses qui était vraiment troublante à l'
époque
était que
différentes communautés de Washington avaient des
raisons et des réponses différentes pour expliquer pourquoi nous
devions entrer en guerre,
il y avait la menace des armes de
destruction massive, il y avait les néoconservateurs.
position d'apporteur de liberté ou de
démocratie
et en tant qu'analyste en tant que journaliste, cela me
paraissait très troublant de constater qu'il y avait
tant d'incohérences pour ne pas dire que l'
un d'entre eux
n'avait pas de sens pour ceux qui présentaient
ces arguments, mais pour moi, c'était
troublant et c'est  quelque chose auquel je
penserai de temps en temps parce que
nous allons devoir nous poser la même question
que nous le faisons actuellement avec l'Ukraine et la Russie, comme
nous allons devoir le faire avec la Chine et
Taiwan potentiellement ou avec une autre partie de
l'Asie-Pacifique indo-pacifique.
avons-nous confiance dans
les dirigeants politiques qui plaident en faveur d'amener
une nation à la guerre
existe-t-il un message cohérent qui ne s'adresse pas
seulement dans le cas de mon pays à notre
population mais aussi à nos alliés,
donc je vois que les deux sont différents dans un sens
et avoir cela  capacité à comprendre dans
mon cas
les signes troublants en analysant ce qui
s'est passé et en m'étant bien sûr retiré
de l'Irak et plus récemment de l'Afghanistan
et en voyant le pays tomber, c'est une
tragédie incroyable et qui aurait dû
être anticipée et cela a été
incroyablement douloureux pour mes amis qui
sont des uniformes qui ont passé une grande partie de leur
carrière
à
anticiper,
oh euh, à parler de l'Afghanistan et à
comprendre
la chute du pays
aux mains des talibans, la rapidité et la rapidité
avec lesquelles cela s'est produit
ont pris beaucoup de gens au dépourvu et cela
ne devrait pas être le cas
pour l'Irak.  le positionnement politique
initial,
je pense qu'en 2022, il a été
dépassé, ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
revient dans la conversation populaire, cela peut encore une fois
comme je l'étais, j'essayais d'
articuler l'idée que lorsqu'on demande à l'État d'
entrer en guerre
et que nous sommes toujours  En tant que Américains, nous allons devoir
répondre de ce que
Powell a dit, c'est le droit d'aller à l'ONU
comme ça
et c'est quelque chose qui
sera tout aussi vital quand on pense
aux conflits à venir dans le futur aussi
parce qu'une fois que vous brisez la confiance comme ça
il est très très difficile de le
reconstruire au niveau national et je dirais qu'à
notre époque, cela devient de plus en
plus difficile de le faire parce qu'il y a tellement, très
peu, je devrais dire, la confiance déjà dans les
grands gouvernements, les plus grandes organisations de systèmes
et c'est quelque chose qui, dans le  Au cours des
deux dernières décennies, la situation s'est littéralement
intensifiée et ne fera que devenir
plus difficile.
Une nation peut-elle
lancer un appel à son peuple pour qu'il soutienne
une opération comme celle-là, encore une fois, une
nation occidentale envahissant un autre pays, c'est
une très très grande question
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
non non je ne pense pas que si je
comprends bien
la
Cour pénale internationale
euh non mais je ne pense pas que ce serait
raisonnable d'essayer de faire ça aux
dirigeants américains de cette époque  au
niveau gouvernemental
non
non,
[la musique]
compte donc avec notre passé pour comprendre
notre avenir si je comprends bien,
avec une organisation comme Wikileaks, cela a
fondamentalement changé la conversation
aux États-Unis
en offrant des preuves de source primaire, le
droit d'Abu Ghraib d'autres instances
comme  que les victimes civiles
et pour tous les efforts que
nous avons déployés depuis pour essayer de
surmonter cela ont fondamentalement changé la
façon dont les autres pays nous perçoivent
et du point de vue de la responsabilité,
dans une perspective de prospective et d'avenir,
sachant que cela fait partie du conflit
et  cela s'est réellement produit, cela
ne vient pas de l'imagination de quelqu'un et que
le public a vécu cela à travers les
fuites de Wikileaks, à travers la couverture médiatique, à travers le
euh,
ils ont le mais, en réalité,
ce n'est pas abstrait pour eux de la manière
dont ils l'ont vécu.  pouvez
lire une histoire, mais vous pouvez en fait maintenant
voir le
rapport original,
vous pouvez regarder une vidéo d'un hélicoptère de combat que vous
connaissez frappant la mauvaise cible,
c'est un nouveau paradigme qui va
continuer et donc en réfléchissant à cela
et à la capacité des dirigeants  mentir
est crucial pour être honnête lorsqu'on
pense à ce qui va se passer dans le
futur. C'est certainement un aspect. Je pense
qu'il faut être capable de considérer
cet aspect humain, la nature du pouvoir,
la nature de la manière dont les gens l'exerceront
et comment la guerre a toujours une importance.
élément politique qui a souvent ce
côté national
le général américain des années 90 ancien
candidat à la présidentielle
je n'ai pas beaucoup d'expérience en lecture
ou je n'ai jamais rencontré Wesley Clark donc il
serait difficile pour moi de dire qu'il est
gentil d'un point de vue générationnel  de l'endroit où s'intégrer étant donné que vous
savez, le
commandant suprême allié en Europe est correct,
mais je n'ai pas d'
opinion bien arrêtée, je n'ai pas passé beaucoup de temps, je
ne l'ai jamais rencontré ni travaillé avec lui ou
quelque chose comme ça,
vous savez, après avoir passé autant de temps
carrière de journaliste, j'ai passé beaucoup de
temps à apprendre à parler aux
gens et, dans de nombreux cas, à amener
des gens à me parler qui ne voulaient pas le faire pour
instaurer la confiance et cela
m'a en fait très bien servi en tant que journaliste.
écrivain de fiction
parce que
beaucoup de gens, quand j'ai quitté mon
travail au Wall Street Journal, je l'ai quitté
pour suivre ce chemin très sinueux d'utilisation de la
fiction et et
et j'ai eu cette expérience vraiment intéressante,
je pensais parce que
travailler au mur  Le street journal aux
États-Unis est un travail très prestigieux
dans le journalisme américain
et je pensais que non, à Washington DC, c'est un
endroit
où votre titre et l'endroit où vous travaillez
comptent lorsque vous rencontrez quelqu'un à
Washington DC,
c'est assez drôle la première chose que les gens
disent, où travaillez-vous  c'est vrai, donc vraiment, c'est
vraiment important, alors
j'ai quitté
ce travail et quand je leur ai dit où je
travaillais, tout le monde était comme wow, c'est vrai, euh
et je pensais que je serais essentiellement une
personne, personne ne me parlerait
plus jamais, n'est-ce pas et j'ai eu beaucoup de
des sources vraiment géniales en qui j'avais confiance et qui m'ont apporté
des choses parfois, je devais les
traquer
quand elles ne voulaient pas me parler et il y a
des allers-retours
quand je quitte le journal même si la
chose la plus intéressante qui m'est arrivée
est que  les gens étaient heureux, ils ont dit que c'était
génial, maintenant nous pouvons enfin parler,
ils n'étaient pas inquiets d'être cités
dans le journal de la même manière
et c'était une évolution intéressante,
car
au fil du temps, pendant quelques années, j'ai
travaillé au journal juste en dessous  trois
ans pendant lesquels
vous vous connaissez en raison de l'
intensité du travail, vous apprenez à
bien connaître les gens parce que vous
leur parlez souvent dans
des situations très stressantes lorsque vous avez besoin de quelque chose
immédiatement et qu'ils ne veulent pas
vous le donner ou vous le donner  vous obtenez le contexte
en ayant une
conversation informelle, mais fondamentalement,
je pense que vous êtes digne de confiance dans ce sens, ce qui
signifie que lorsque vous faites un rapport et
couvrez s'il s'agit d'une entreprise, d'un
ministère ou d'une agence,
même les dernières nouvelles
étant la personne à qui ils veulent parler
parce qu'ils savent que vous réussirez
lorsque les gens sont négligents avec les faits
ou
inconsidérés avec leurs sources,
il est difficile de développer une
relation de confiance même s'il y a un peu d'
antagonisme,
vous voulez être la personne qui lorsque de mauvaises
nouvelles arrivent  les gens vous disent que c'est
comme mon ancienne vie de journaliste
maintenant lorsque je travaille sur ces livres comme
Ghost Fleet qui, même s'il contient
ces notes de bas de page très complètes, les notes de fin
à la fin, les détails
sont des articles de recherche de source primaire,
tout ce que
nous cherchons toujours
à obtenir  l'élément humain, c'est vrai parce qu'un
bon roman concerne fondamentalement les gens
et c'est presque important, au
niveau anthropologique,
juste pour savoir
comment transmettre la réalité de quelqu'un.
J'essaie constamment de comprendre
ce que ça fait d'être littéralement assis à
la place de quelqu'un ou de  me mettre à la place de quelqu'un
et j'aborde cela avec beaucoup d'
humilité
et je pense
que c'est vraiment très important de ne
jamais essayer d'être dans une position où
vous dites à quelqu'un, hé, je suis la
personne la plus intelligente dans la pièce, j'en sais plus
que  surtout quand vous écrivez
sur l'avenir et des choses qui ne se sont pas
encore produites
directement,
je veux dire, c'est
un grand pays, il y a beaucoup de
gens différents
non mais je veux vraiment bien faire ce travail,
aller dans des pièces où  je suis la
personne la moins experte,
qu'il s'agisse d'un domaine que vous connaissez dans le
domaine de la sécurité ou que je travaille avec des personnes
qui ont beaucoup plus d'expérience que moi,
euh,
vous savez, comprendre ce que je peux apporter à
cette conversation et être
clair avec moi-même à ce sujet
et comprendre ce que  ce qu'ils ont à
offrir est vraiment important, ce
qui est intéressant dans l'idée que
vous avez mentionnée, à savoir si nous
poursuivons les gens pour obtenir des
informations ou des choses,
il y a certainement des moments où nous voulons
euh, vous savez, en nous dans la flotte fantôme  J'essaie
de décrire ce que c'est que de piloter un
chasseur F-35 si vous êtes poursuivi par
un missile chinois.
Je ne suis pas pilote, je ne me suis jamais assis dans un
F-35, vous savez, il pouvait voler,
alors nous avons atteint notre  communauté
et euh
ouais, exactement
n'importe quel avion,
il n'y a plus d'avions furtifs, qu'il
pleuve, que ce soit de la peinture qui s'en
détache ou que vous connaissez un radar à large bande,
donc nous avons contacté certains de nos contacts
et relations au sujet de personnes qui ont piloté
ce genre d'avions
et qui pourraient obtenir  un peu de
perspective à partir de là et vous savez que nous faisons
attention à des choses comme les
classifications et les autorisations et
vous savez que les gens ne nous diront pas des choses qu'ils
ne sont pas censés faire évidemment, mais
c'est vraiment important parce que nous voulons
décrire ce que
c'est  vous pourriez en fait avoir l'impression d'être
poursuivi par un missile chinois qui
se dirige
vers un élément matériel piraté de votre
propre avion,
ce que ce serait de ne plus faire confiance à
votre machine, alors que vous avez passé
toute votre carrière à travailler pour vous mettre
derrière le  Tenez bon et tout d'un coup, en un
instant, vous réalisez que c'est la plus grande
vulnérabilité de toutes et vous allez
mourir
euh c'est une chose vraiment difficile à écrire en
tant que profane, en tant qu'étranger,
alors alors nous faisons ça, euh,
je pense que c'est vraiment un problème.  une
partie essentielle de la raison pour laquelle le travail que nous effectuons peut être
connecté
maintenant ayant écrit le
fantôme de Leflot
ayant un contrôle écrit qui est sorti
aux États-Unis en 2020,
les gens viennent de plus en plus vers nous pour avoir
des conversations sur ce qui s'en vient pour poser
des questions sur le futur environnement opérationnel
et donc ceux  les conversations deviennent de plus
en plus faciles chaque année,
mais une autre façon de penser à
ces projets est que tout le monde est en un
sens une expérience lorsque nous avons écrit ghost
la flat fenton, nous ne savions pas si
quelqu'un allait le lire ou si on
se moquerait de lui
pour  écrire un roman pour imiter le vieux
Tom Clancy de 1986
euh
tempête rouge se levant euh qui en
france a un titre différent mais
euh
mais nous avons estimé que cela valait le risque
de la même manière avec le contrôle, nous avons écrit un
livre qui ne parle pas d'une
autre guerre  avec la Chine, ce n'est pas
du
tout ça, c'est dit à Washington DC,
c'est une histoire de contre-terrorisme
[Musique]
je fais juste remarquer que chaque
projet
est une expérience
euh
euh j'ai beaucoup d'inquiétudes pour les
deux prochaines années  euh,
surtout à la lumière de ce qui
se passe en Ukraine, l'
une des choses qui m'inquiète
concerne cette idée d'un
récit national qui, à partir de si vous êtes Vladimir
Poutine, en pensant à l'histoire russe
et aux années qu'il lui reste dans sa
vie
et le pouvoir qu'il a amassé, l'argent qu'il a, il a
mis en banque les gens qui
gardent son argent pour lui, il est
très probablement l'homme le plus riche du monde
et il a beaucoup à perdre personnellement mais n'a
pourtant rien à perdre en même temps au niveau
national,
l'un de mes  Ce qui inquiète, c'est que l'une des
grandes expériences qu'il a menées
avec l'invasion de l'Ukraine, où il a
tenté et voulu mener une
frappe chirurgicale, une campagne d'information qui a
complètement échoué,
est que cet objectif consistait en grande partie à
diviser l'Europe politiquement,
l'alliance de l'OTAN en particulier
et il  il en a encore d'autres
pour moi ouais il ne l'a pas fait ouais ouais c'est
mon analyse, c'est comme ça que je
la comprends
et il y a des gens qui sont plus experts
sur la Russie que moi pour être clair, c'est
encore une fois quelque chose sur lequel je dois être clair
mais je vais juste suivre mon
instinct et
il lui reste encore quelques leviers pour
essayer d'atteindre ces objectifs,
ses campagnes de guerre de l'information ne
fonctionnent pas correctement, lequel Poutine
mais la
tentative de fracturer l'
alliance de l'OTAN  la cohérence est correcte,
mais que se passerait-il s'il devait prendre
une mesure impliquant une frappe militaire
contre la nation de l'OTAN, peut-être un
aérodrome en Pologne où
transitent des missiles javelots, peut-être que c'est
contre la Finlande, une
nation voisine qui
envisage récemment de rejoindre l'OTAN pour forcer l'
article  5 discussion au sein de l'OTAN comme
moyen
de faire en sorte que l'alliance décide réellement de quoi
il s'agit
et
j'ai été l'une de mes plus grandes surprises.
On me demande parfois ce qui vous a surpris
dans ce conflit
et l'une des choses qui
m'a surpris a été si  jusqu'à présent, l'unité en Europe
et aussi à travers l'Atlantique avec les États-Unis et le Royaume-
Uni
sur la fourniture d'armes sur la fourniture de ressources, il
n'y a pas eu de fracture dans
cette relation,
mais nous sommes encore au début de ce jeu,
nous n'avons pas traversé une  En plein hiver,
mais
sans l'énergie russe, nous ne savons toujours pas ce qui nous
attend stratégiquement à l'automne
et donc les deux prochaines années
me semblent vraiment très importantes du
point de vue des six prochains mois, car
pendant ce temps, Xi Xinping,
même s'il a peut-être pour objectif de
prendre Taiwan.  peu importe ce à quoi cela pourrait
ressembler d'ici 2027 ou quel que soit
l'objectif réel, il s'agit
certainement d'observer, d'apprendre et d'
écouter et de voir à quel point l'
Amérique en particulier
sera engagée envers ses obligations de défense européenne,
même si en même temps,
bien sûr, elle en
crée de nouvelles.  dans le Pacifique comme
en août
par exemple avec le Royaume-Uni et l'Australie
[Musique]
c'est là que Peter et moi faisons le bien,
nous nous affrontons constamment,
donc nous devons nous asseoir de l'autre côté de la table
d'après ce que je viens de dire,
l'une des façons  je pourrais déballer ce
serait
si Poutine lui-même en fait
non non non
perspective
américaine
seulement
ouais je veux dire je pense que nous sommes en
territoire inconnu en termes de ce concept
de guerre économique et pour les intérêts américains,
notre politique va devoir soudainement
venir  Nous devons comprendre le fait que nous venons de
déconnecter la Russie occidentale
et que nous ne savons pas encore l'un des effets à long terme sur nos
relations commerciales avec l'Europe,
mais je pense que les intérêts généraux des États-Unis se
concentrent de plus en plus de
manière significative sur  l'Asie-
Pacifique en termes de maintien de la Chine au sein de
sa deuxième chaîne d'îles
en gardant nos alliés, en particulier l'Australie,
dont nous réalisons que je pense que d'année en année
est encore plus important pour nous en termes
de projection de puissance et quand vous regardez
l'
ambition chinoise globale pour
euh belton road one Belt One Road,
comprenant que cela s'inscrit dans le genre
de chaos de la tradition navale américaine,
comme si vous essayiez de contrôler les
lignes de communication maritimes à l'échelle mondiale,
vous essayez de contrôler les
réseaux d'information à l'échelle mondiale,
nous devons trouver des moyens  pour contrer
cela et la question est, je pense, vraiment
importante
et centrée sur cette notion de savoir si
cette contre-attaque est
économique et politique ou si c'est une
puissance dure, n'est-ce pas davantage ancré dans la
défense
et donc c'est l'un des
principes constants  questions de savoir comment contrer
la Chine parce que nous allons vivre
dans un monde où l'économie chinoise
est plus grande que celle de toute autre nation au
monde, les dépenses militaires
pourraient-elles
devenir essentiellement supérieures aux nôtres d'ici
la fin de cette décennie,
où leur armée est plus importante ?
professionnel maintenant, il s'agit
également d'implications politiques à l'intérieur de la Chine, ce qui est
une autre conversation, mais
c'est l'une des questions américaines constantes dont
il est très difficile de parler :
comment vivez-vous dans un monde, quel
genre de nation l'Amérique peut-elle être quand la Chine
va le devenir ?
plus puissant économiquement, ce qui
n'est jamais arrivé pour nous auparavant et
potentiellement plus capable et plus
puissant militairement,
ce qui me fascine dans cette question
de l'héritage et de l'histoire de la Chine et
leur colère face aux guerres de l'opium est toujours
très réelle, mais c'est le parti communiste
lui-même  est encore assez jeune, n'est-ce pas, vous
savez, le parti communiste, je pense, a été
formé en 1928, mais la nation elle-même date de
1949, vous connaissez la Chine moderne,
une des choses que je me suis demandée, c'est combien
de temps le parti communiste chinois peut-il
survivre aux contradictions inhérentes à
cette société.  chaque année, surtout à mesure que
leur secteur technologique se développe et que leur
armée devient plus professionnelle, cela
va leur imposer des
moments vraiment très difficiles, je veux dire, c'est
pourquoi, en fantôme plat, nous avons postulé que le
parti communiste chinois avait disparu,
vous savez que ce n'est tout simplement pas possible.  Cela n'a
plus aucun sens de diriger ce pays,
mais là, c'est subordonner le PLA,
gérer une économie qui ne répond pas
à la planification centrale,
c'est une énigme fascinante pour eux
et la société
[Musique]
donc l'un des
principaux intérêts que cette
montée de  La Chine présente est la suivante : comment pouvez-vous
maintenir l'économie mondiale et
les réseaux politiques et culturels toujours alignés
autour d'un système occidental et ouvert ?
Cela me semble être la chose la plus importante que
les États-Unis doivent pouvoir faire
pour lutter contre cet aspect de la
Chine.  nous ne pouvons pas nous
permettre de les surpasser économiquement,
notre pays est trop petit, ce
qui est une chose étrange à dire en tant
qu'américain, car notre pays est, vous le savez, le
triomphe économique du monde,
non, pas  Intellectuellement, je dirais
qu'économiquement, euh, en tant que centre d'
innovation et cela fait
partie de cette vision, si l'Amérique,
ouais, si l'Amérique perd sa capacité à être
le lieu et cela semble très cliché
où les gens les plus intelligents du monde
veulent venir gagner de l'argent et  soyez libres,
alors nous allons être dans une très mauvaise
situation si nous avons une société trop
extrême, trop violente, voire dysfonctionnelle,
tout cela va éroder cela et cela
peut être lent, cela peut être lent
en fait,
nous ne sommes pas non nous.  Nous n'en sommes pas encore là,
heureusement, oui,
je pense que chaque année, cela deviendra de plus
en plus difficile si notre
système politique continue à être dysfonctionnel. Je
pense que nous pouvons continuer, d'autant plus que
nous sommes à
nouveau tellement liés économiquement jusqu'à un certain point,
mais l'offre d'un point de vue chinois
nous  nous sommes dans une situation de concurrence, en
particulier avec l'Europe,
je pense que c'est l'une des
questions constantes pour la Chine. La Chine peut-elle
détourner l'Europe de son
orientation occidentale vers l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique ?
C'est un concept stratégique très profond
à considérer car il est  bien
sûr, il ne s'agit pas, comme je l'ai dit
plus tôt, d'une question de puissance dure, mais d'
attrait économique et d'incitation aux opportunités
et actuellement, à cause
du système politique chinois, il est
répressif, ce n'est pas un endroit où nous sommes,
il est très difficile de faire des affaires, euh,
c'est difficile,
mais dans le  la stratégie centenaire à long terme du 21e siècle
que les États-Unis et la Chine envisagent
à la fin du 22e 21e siècle en
réfléchissant à quelle nation va
prospérer,
alors il faut
répondre à cette question, c'est
presque certaines personnes l'ont appelé comme
le  opéra
la capacité de devenir presque dans notre
cas maintenir le système d'exploitation
du monde comme certains
l'ont décrit ou si les chinois sont capables de le recâbler
parce que cela affecte tout,
de la primauté du dollar
à la capacité de capter la valeur économique
et  l'innovation pour contrôler les routes commerciales
le mouvement physique des objets nous pourrions
avoir des révolutions dans
l'impression 3D qui changent la façon dont les produits
sont fabriqués dans les usines qui permettent à un
national, vous savez, le
réveil de l'industrie manufacturière nous pourrions
devenir moins dépendants du pétrole au
Moyen-Orient grâce à l'énergie
solaire  l'énergie ou peut-être la fusion,
mais fondamentalement, les routes commerciales du
monde seront toujours tout aussi vitales
et j'ai l'air un peu old school
en disant cela, mais autant je pense
à l'avenir, plus vous devez toujours vous
souvenir du passé,
c'est encore une fois l'un de ceux-là.  En réalité, je pense que les
moyens fondamentaux
d'envisager ce qui s'en vient, en particulier
à plus long terme, vous savez qu'une grande partie
du travail que je fais est axée sur les
10 à 20 prochaines années, en quelque sorte au début de
20 ans.
que 2050 2060, je veux dire, vous devez bien sûr
aussi parler de l'espace,
au moins à proximité de l'espace, mais surtout en
regardant les schémas plus larges de
mouvements humains que vous connaissez au cours des 2 300 dernières
années, alors que nous commencions à entrer dans l'ère du
commerce maritime et bien sûr  maintenant, nous
avons l'aviation
qui va rester et rester tout
aussi importante qu'elle l'a jamais été, même si
elle change légèrement de forme de
revenus.
La première, je dirais,
revient à cette idée d'être le
lieu physique
même si nous allons entrer dans un monde plus
monde virtualisé où les gens veulent
venir et prospérer,
la seconde serait de créer un bien commun mondial sécurisé
du point de vue de la défense, ce qui
signifie cyber, cela signifie de
plus en plus d'espace et bien sûr la mer
que nous pouvons affecter, laisser les autres être
comme on dit en économie des passagers clandestins.
notre force est que vous pouvez envoyer
des navires à travers un océan sans vous soucier
de leur passage de l'autre côté, c'est
un rôle que la Chine n'a pas voulu
jouer, cela coûte très cher et nous pouvons
à peine nous permettre de le faire avec notre propre marine
et peut-être avec  le troisième, je dirais
l'esthétique, le maintien
et la conservation
des relations qui nous ont bien servi au
siècle dernier et je pense aux
relations entre les États-Unis et l'Europe avec nos alliés, il y a une
autre façon de penser à
ce troisième point qui est de savoir si vous pouvez vous faire de
nouveaux amis, n'est-ce
pas ?
parce que nous allons avoir
des troubles et des turbulences dans des pays donnés,
certains pays pourraient sortir de notre orbite,
mais l'idée est que si l'Amérique
doit être non seulement un endroit où les gens veulent
venir comme au premier point, mais
simultanément, alors que nous regardons, nous  Nous devons
rester engagés dans le monde à ce
niveau
et être capables de garder les gens à
nos côtés et c'est bien sûr une question de
confiance, comme vous le savez, à propos de vos
points précédents sur l'Irak, c'est une question d'
opportunité pour les gens
au niveau des dirigeants, mais aussi  au
niveau de la rue et de plus en plus, et c'est un
peu mon cerveau futuriste,
la façon dont un pays comme l'Amérique peut
attirer les gens est autant une question d'
idée et bien sûr, les idées ont des
incohérences et des contradictions, je le
sais,
mais la notion d'idée d'un  l'histoire est
toujours très importante pour les
relations internationales et peut-être encore
plus à mesure que nous devenons de plus en plus
virtualisés, l'idée est
dans un sens ce que
j'allais faire une blague à propos du
croissant café
non euh
je dirais les
frites frites dans  la France est en fait
avec des frites de liberté, des
frites ouais, euh, écoute, je veux dire, d'un
point de vue européen,
si l'Amérique est un pays jeune, l'
Union européenne elle-même est encore une très
jeune expérience,
vous savez, si vous considérez l'idée
d'éviter
quand je vivais en France  au milieu des
années 90,
lors de l'émergence de l'
Union européenne, il était très intéressant
d'entendre les Français parler de
la montée de l'UE comme d'un moyen de
réfléchir à
ce qu'il fallait faire de l'Allemagne au 21e
siècle
et je pense donc  une Europe pacifique où
l'Union européenne est viable et permet
une
intégration économique et je ne suis pas quelqu'un qui
croit complètement que l'
intégration économique est bien sûr quelque chose qui
peut empêcher la guerre de se produire, nos deux
guerres mondiales au 20e et 20e siècle
prouvent que ce n'est pas la bonne solution.  cas,
mais je pense que cela vous donne une meilleure
chance d'éviter les conflits ou de créer
à partir de valeurs non partagées, au moins d'intérêts partagés,
donc je dirais que la poursuite de l'expérience européenne
est importante
étant donné que je n'ai pas parlé de l'idée du
réchauffement climatique et en quelque sorte  les aspects
de la réinvention de l'économie énergétique,
l'Europe peut avoir une meilleure avance
que les États-Unis dans ce domaine
et cela présente potentiellement un avantage stratégique.
Le troisième, je dirais,
le troisième, je dirais,
concerne les transformations sociétales
et ce
n'est pas moi spécifiquement.  J'essaie de mentionner
le livre mais plutôt que nous sommes dans une
époque où
les populations vont avoir de moins en
moins d'opportunités économiques
et qu'en Europe, il y a un niveau très élevé
dans le contrat social, bien
plus élevé qu'en Amérique
ce que les gens attendent en termes de
soins de santé.  en termes d'avantages, savoir si nous
avons un revenu de base
sera un
problème très très difficile,
en particulier pour les pays les plus riches d'Europe,
car les gens sont très investis dans
ce qui se passe et il sera
économiquement de plus en plus difficile
de remplir ces obligations,
ce qui a des implications pour  tout,
depuis
les dépenses de défense,
parce que si vous envisagez la budgétisation
comme un jeu à somme nulle, ce qui signifie que l'argent d'
un compte va aller à l'autre,
payons-nous pour le revenu de base ou payons-nous pour des
escadrons de combattants de six générations,
ce qui est un  chose très difficile à
concilier et qui a d'énormes implications euh
et cela me fascine en tant que question, certaines des
courtes fictions sur lesquelles j'ai
travaillé essayaient de
comprendre que même d'un
point de vue français,
euh, quels sont les  les choix que vous
connaissez pourraient-ils, par exemple, dans ce
scénario, conserver son
armée de forces humaines à une époque des années
2040 où de nombreux autres pays européens
ont automatisé leurs forces et les ont gardées
comme élément de crise,
c'est de la taille d'un robot, vous le mettez dans une grotte  ou
dans un bunker et vous ne l'utilisez que lorsque vous en avez
besoin,
mais il y a des
raisons culturelles, il y a des raisons politiques de faire cela et c'est vraiment
d'un point de vue futur, vraiment
très intéressant et donc cela est lié à
cette troisième
notion sur la gestion de ce
problème, de
cette chose  Ce à quoi je pense
le plus souvent avec la Chine, c'est si vous êtes du point de vue de Xi Xin Ping
ou si vous êtes un haut responsable du parti communiste,
comment empêcher le pays
de s'effondrer,
comment
conserver un
système politique cohérent
qui est si difficile  faire là, l'
hétérogénéité de l'économie et de la
culture dans cette société, étant donné son
ampleur,
est sans précédent dans l'histoire de l'humanité,
d'autant plus qu'elle entre en collision avec la modernité,
donc
vous savez, il y a une phrase à Washington
DC, vous savez quels sont les facteurs les plus importants
et les plus importants  dans n'importe quelle
situation, essayer d'analyser et de
comprendre numéro un, c'est la politique,
numéro deux, c'est la politique et numéro
trois, c'est la politique
avec la Chine, c'est un peu comme ça, ce qui est le numéro un, empêche le
pays de s'effondrer,
numéro deux, empêche le pays de s'effondrer,
numéro trois, etc.,
mais mais  pour offrir plus de précision sur
les alternatives pour deux et trois,
vous avez un changement démographique dans cette
société qui se produit en même
temps qu'un changement économique, ce qui signifie que
vous allez regarder une
population vieillissante dont nous aurons
besoin de plus en plus  l'État se soucie de lui,
même si l'économie croît
en même temps que les coûts de la
main-d'œuvre augmentent dans le secteur commercial. Vous assistez à une délocalisation de
la fabrication de la Chine vers le Vietnam vers
d'autres pays qui sont plus
acceptables politiquement
et comme l'Europe, ce troisième point
sur
l'équilibre.  cette notion de
comment nourrir
un pays avec
une population aussi nombreuse au travail avec le
sentiment de prospérer, investie
dans un système de parti communiste qui a
tant de contradictions
et c'est aussi une proposition très coûteuse
que si je devais essayer d'y
réfléchir
quelles sont les choses qui pourraient nuire à l'
essor militaire et stratégique de la Chine, il
s'agit de ce dernier point,
en particulier
du commerce,
qui est très difficile euh
c'est difficile pour moi euh parce que je
continue de le voir à travers
la perspective de quelqu'un comme du
point de vue de Vladimir Poutine  de vue donc
c'est comme ça que je vais y répondre euh
c'est une excellente question euh je pense que c'est absolument
beaucoup plus difficile de savoir
que si vous êtes un
expatrié professionnel, vous pourriez simplement
être dans n'importe quelle capitale internationale, je pense
que c'est possible je  Je veux dire, d'après mon
expérience,
c'est drôle, en fait, je voulais être
ambassadeur en Russie. J'étais vraiment passionné de
skateboard quand j'avais
10, 11, 12 ans et en même temps,
j'étudiais le
russe avec un tuteur
à l'université.  université de Washington Seattle,
je serais littéralement emmené et conduit
vers
le
j'utiliserais le doctorat en géorgien
[Musique]
je pense que c'est vraiment difficile de comprendre
profondément une culture
sans avoir eu une expérience dans cette
langue, je pense que c'est vraiment difficile,
je pense qu'en tant que personne qui
essaie d'utiliser la fiction et d'
imaginer
non seulement d'
autres sociétés, d'autres cultures, d'
autres emplois,
mais aussi l'avenir lui-même si vous pouvez
commencer par comprendre ce que vous ne savez pas
et c'est un peu comme ce que je
disais plus tôt
qui vous aide à éviter certains  de ce
piège mais mais absolument il y a une
vous savez une des expériences que nous avons eues
euh ce n'est pas un secret mais c'est un
aspect de Ghost Fleet Phantom je ne suis jamais
allé à Hawaï et nous avons écrit de nombreuses
scènes à Hawaï
donc
spoiler
l'histoire commence  en fait, avec une
découverte énergétique, la Chine a un
moment où il y a littéralement un avant
et un après dans la réalisation qu'elle peut atteindre
une forme d'indépendance énergétique,
mais la manière la plus effrayante du
livre, lorsque vous dépassez cela, commence, c'est
la manière réelle dont le  la troisième guerre mondiale
commence bien cette question de savoir si elle
commence par
un missile qui survole le pôle nord,
est-ce un sous-marin qui se cache et
coule un porte-avions
en écrivant ce livre, nous avons beaucoup réfléchi à
cette question, c'est peut-être la question la plus
importante, eh
bien  un faux drapeau fait partie de la façon dont cela
fonctionne,
mais nous avons
d'abord commencé avec Warren's Space
et nous l'avons regardé du point de vue d'
un astronaute américain
sur la station spatiale internationale
et je vais avoir un type de spoiler
qui est verrouillé par ces
cosmonautes russes.  parce qu'ils prennent le
contrôle de la station
et
assez rapidement
l'histoire se déplace à Hawaï parce qu'un
peu plus de spoiler, la
Chine s'empare d'Hawaï, ce qui est à un certain
niveau une
question scandaleuse à poser, est-ce que cela pourrait vraiment
arriver mais ils utilisent un moyen d'invasion
avec des forces spéciales qui n'est pas sans rappeler  comment ils ont
envahi l'Afghanistan en 1979, alors les
chinois utilisent des cargos rouliers
pour s'arrêter au quai,
d'abord il y a des SUV chinois bon marché qui
arrivent sur le marché local et
ensuite c'est un
tank puis un véhicule blindé et  un
autre tank
et ce genre de tromperie,
vous savez, comment vous cachez-vous à la vue de tous,
n'est-ce pas, c'est quelque chose auquel
nous réfléchissons maintenant avec l'Ukraine, bien
sûr, comment mobiliser une force d'invasion
capable de s'emparer du territoire des
États-Unis, c'est  l'exercice c'est
l'ancienne méthode, c'est vrai, c'est
efficace, c'est vrai, je veux dire, les russes l'ont fait,
je veux dire, c'est le récit, vous
savez,
ouais,
mais l'
exercice que l'
OTAN effectue n'implique pas de traverser la
Russie, vous savez,
euh, tout comme la Russie a traversé l'Ukraine,
n'est-ce pas,
ils aussi  objectifs d'objet, je pense que c'est trop
vrai euh et parfois, bien sûr, vous
savez que vous avez la force de dissuasion,
l'aspiration à dissuader en montrant de quoi
vous êtes capable
en vous engageant dans la manœuvre complexe et le
mouvement de dizaines de milliers de forces. Le
cas de l'OTAN différentes nations différentes
dans notre  Dans le cas où nous faisons quelques pays,
je ne sais pas si les exercices militaires
offrent réellement une dissuasion,
mais c'est une autre conversation,
mais cette notion de
comment
comprendre un environnement sans y avoir
été et
nous avons eu une critique d'un des
journaux d'Hawaï.  l'annonceur vedette d'Honolulu
et mon co-scénariste étaient allés un peu à Hawaï,
mais
ils étaient vraiment satisfaits de la qualité de
notre description d'Hawaï
et vous savez, du point de vue de la pratique,
vu que cela a réussi avec eux, ils
l'ont bien reçu,
cela a beaucoup soulagé  de stress que j'ai eu et
j'ai en quelque sorte pensé que
je ne voulais plus jamais faire cette erreur
d'écrire un livre et de ne pas aller sur
place et de voir le sol parler aux
gens,
euh encore et peut-être que c'est la vanité d'
un premier roman, tu sais, essayer  besoin
de faire ça correctement, nous n'avions pas vraiment
beaucoup de choix,
mais j'ai l'impression que c'était un très très
grand moment de réalisation que vous
savez de manière créative, parfois vous prenez ce
risque et cela peut être payant, mais cela
peut aussi ne pas être le cas et cela  et cela nous ramène
à l'idée de crédibilité, vous savez,
tout comme vous essayez de comprendre
la langue que parle une culture, vous savez
qu'en tant que civil écrivant sur l'
armée, il existe une manière similaire de
parler
qu'il est essentiel de comprendre et elle ne consiste pas
seulement à utiliser  acronymes
le raccourci que vous connaissez si vous êtes assis dans un
bar avec des gens qui reviennent d'
un déploiement ou qui vont en déploiement, la
conversation qu'ils ont est assez
riche en acronymes qui, pour un étranger, est
impénétrable et cela fait partie de la
culture, c'est vrai que ce langage est unique
mais être capable essentiellement d'essayer de
mieux comprendre comment communiquer
avec les
militaires qui sont vos
lecteurs et qui ont également besoin de croire à
l'histoire que vous créez,
surtout si elle est
racontée dans le futur, peut-être qu'ils pensent que c'est
tiré par les cheveux ou non  possible, si vous
repoussez vraiment un peu les limites de ce qui est
possible,
il est essentiel de pouvoir essayer d'entrer dans
ce genre de langage et il ne s'agit
pas seulement de dialoguer pour qu'un
personnage dise la bonne chose,
il s'agit également de
comprendre ce que quoi.  et encore une fois, de
cette manière anthropologique, qu'est-ce qui compte pour
eux, comment entretiennent-ils leurs relations avec leurs
familles,
comment font-ils, comment traitent-ils les
étrangers, euh, ce sont tous des
aspects cruciaux auxquels je pense, vous savez
ce que vous appelez la construction du monde,
vous connaissez ces aspects.  Je pense qu'il y a une
autre façon dont j'y pense
aussi, euh vous savez, ce
ne sont pas les
faits et les détails que vous avez dans une histoire
qui sont importants, c'est ce que vous laissez
de côté, vraiment, en
comprenant simplement en donnant au
lecteur
suffisamment de choses pour qu'il puisse faire  partie du
film dans leur propre esprit
mais aussi leur permettre,
j'aimerais penser à apprendre un
peu aussi
parce qu'il n'y a rien de pire, il n'y
a rien de pire que de
lire quelque chose où vous avez l'impression d'
être sermonné comme si c'était trop
vrai ou vous  Je perds la capacité de
me situer dans ce film quand j'écris,
je regarde littéralement le film vous savez et c'est
comme ça que mon cerveau fonctionne, chaque
écrivain est différent,
mais surtout dans les thrillers d'équitation et
les thrillers techno où c'est très
viscéral, il y a de l'action dans laquelle
nous sommes  je parle d'
avions de combat, de flottes fantômes ou de
sous-marins et
tout, euh,
c'est vraiment important pour moi de pouvoir
bien voir la scène et de pouvoir
la déplacer
dans ces différentes perspectives
et cela vous permet, je pense, de vraiment
comprendre
comme si vous  Je dis littéralement à quelqu'un
ce qui s'est passé,
d'un point de vue analytique et narratif,
pour moi, c'est l'un des
moyens les plus simples de surmonter le blocage de l'écrivain. Le blocage
de l'écrivain est de répondre à cette
question.  un
point que
les gens perdent souvent de vue lorsqu'ils se
concentrent sur leurs propres idées
[Musique] [
Musique]
l'une des façons dont j'y pense est de savoir à
quoi ça ressemble de vivre dans un monde dans
lequel toutes ces technologies, qu'il s'agisse de
chiens robots policiers  que ce soit des
logiciels de reconnaissance faciale partout où je
vais, comment cela change-t-il vous savez comment je
me comporte, mais
pas seulement comment je me comporte, mais comment je pense que
vous savez que l'idée d'autocensure dans
certains régimes est quelque chose que les gens
développent naturellement, vous savez, pouvez-vous
y entrer  une ère de surveillance totale où
tout, de la montre que vous portez à la
voiture que vous venez de sortir du
restaurant où vous mangez, est
déjà là avec votre carte de crédit et
votre iphone dans une certaine mesure,
nous sommes à un point où
cela va
comme ça
et la question est de savoir
quelle est la prochaine étape
fondamentalement quand je pense à
ce monde IA et robotisé, vous
savez dans quel monde je veux
vivre, et à partir de là, travailler à rebours
et et cela pour moi signifie que si je devais
décomposez cela un peu,
vous savez, en pensant à
la capacité de ne pas
ressentir, au sens humain du terme, comme si vous étiez
constamment surveillé, c'est
extrêmement stressant et inconfortable
et je pense que c'est une
expérience préjudiciable à vivre
et nous y sommes déjà et il y
a un peu  un peu comme ça euh tu
sais citation sur la paranoïa tu sais
que je ne vais probablement pas dire
correctement euh mais l'idée que tu sais
si ce n'est pas que tu es, voyons
ce n'est pas qu'ils ne te
regardent pas tu es  tout simplement pas
assez paranoïaque ou quelque chose comme ça
et
entre nos iPhones et nos
cartes de crédit, la quantité de données que vous
pouvez utiliser pour modéliser le comportement de quelqu'un et
avec l'IA, vous savez, les jumeler et créer
essentiellement un totem factuel de leur vie
de leur existence
commence  pour modifier fondamentalement les
relations que nous entretenons les uns avec les
autres
et ce qui est peut-être le plus troublant dans
ce monde, c'est de ne pas s'en rendre compte, ce sont
les gens qui avancent essentiellement en
swipant sur les applications en
tapant sur un téléphone pour payer et ne
voient pas réellement tout cela se produire à cause
du  Ce qui est frustrant à propos de
bon nombre des technologies les plus efficaces
comme celle-ci, c'est qu'elles sont invisibles, mais nous
ne les percevons pas. C'est, je pense, l'un
des défis vraiment intéressants
avec l'IA, car si quelqu'un doit
être contrarié ou même enragé à propos d'
une technologie basée sur l'IA.  prise de décision peut-être que cela figure
dans leur rapport de crédit
peut-être qu'ils n'ont pas réussi à obtenir un prêt
ils ne savent pas que ce logiciel était
basé sur des données
qui ne leur permettraient jamais d'obtenir un
prêt parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas le bon profil
et nous n'avons pas cette compréhension au
niveau de la société civile de la façon dont tout cela
fonctionne, donc c'est une question à la fois d'
éducation,
cet été va être très très
chargé aux États-Unis parce que
la Cour suprême des États-Unis est la plus  susceptible de
réécrire essentiellement
permettre aux États de réécrire les lois sur l'avortement être
beaucoup plus restrictives, c'est horrible et
ce que cela signifie également, selon vous, que
nous allons devoir réfléchir à cette
question de la vie privée de manière très réelle, ce
n'est pas une question abstraite lorsque quelqu'un
quand quelqu'un qui a
une application qui suit son cycle menstruel
et soudain,
ce sont potentiellement des données que les
forces de l'ordre d'un État qui a une
loi restrictive sur l'avortement
pourraient utiliser pour la poursuivre en justice,
peut-être même si elle est hors de l'État
lorsqu'elle a avorté  utiliser leurs
données de localisation ou leurs reçus de carte de crédit
et nous n'avons pas de
conversation significative à ce sujet et
vous avez demandé s'il est trop tard, n'est-ce pas,
pour pouvoir avoir cette
conversation, il y a
un risque réel, il y en
a beaucoup,
il y a une chance que nous le fassions  Il faudra
avoir ce débat très bientôt,
mais
quand on regarde comment les lois sont élaborées
aux États-Unis, quand on regarde les mouvements
qui ont été nécessaires
au niveau politique
pour changer quelque chose d'aussi fondamental que les
droits sur les données,
qui n'est pas une question brûlante aux
États-Unis.  personne ne s'en soucie, mais c'est vital que
cela nécessitera
et peut-être que c'est un aspect de ce qui
se passe
avec l'abrogation de l'option roe versus wade, c'est
que cela force une conversation très réelle et immédiate
qui mène à des mesures en matière de
protection des données,
mais c'est d'un point de vue politique du point de vue politique.
d'un autre côté, d'un point de vue d'entreprise,
quelle est l'obligation morale et éthique
d'une entreprise technologique, n'est-ce pas
et c'est quelque chose sur lequel je ne
pense pas que nous ayons encore eu de débat publiquement
et nous devons absolument
causer du mal, je veux dire si vous  pensez à
la capacité de causer du mal avec vos
électrons, vous savez, vous savez qu'il existe une
myriade de façons de le faire avec
des algorithmes, plus spécifiquement dans les médias sociaux,
comment pouvons-nous ensuite nous défendre en tant
qu'individus alors que
les politiciens ne s'en soucient peut-être pas, je veux dire,
c'est une question de
non  juste du plaidoyer mais mais du déterminisme
et j'aime dire que je suis un optimiste qui
regarde dans l'abîme,
c'est vrai,
je crois au potentiel et
aux possibilités humaines,
mais j'ai beaucoup de nuits blanches
à penser à tout ce qui pourrait
arriver dans le futur dans le proche  terme
et et c'est une de ces périodes où il a
été très difficile d'
y réfléchir et d'essayer de trouver
quelque chose qui ne me sorte pas
d'une situation très sombre et très très déprimante
euh
vous savez l'année prochaine environ à cet
égard  si je veux si je veux avoir de
l'espoir, c'est que
parfois le changement vient d'
une perspective orthogonale et alternative,
extérieure,
donc peut-être
qu'un débat
dans la rue sur l'avortement
oblige aussi à enfin s'attaquer
à cette question des données et de la vie privée,
car cela  a des
implications très réelles pour la sûreté
et la sécurité des femmes en Amérique
qu'Edward Snowden a pu
produire en volant des données directement dans
des fichiers
et qu'il se retrouve à Moscou en
tant que fugitif via Hong Kong
me semble
et c'est un
vous savez, c'est mon mon mon
mon conspirateur vous savez romancier espion
euh
état d'esprit  comme comme comme comme comme une
opération que tu ne pouvais pas, je ne pouvais pas
inventer ça et l'écrire
euh c'est mon instinct en regardant
que
j'ai beaucoup d'amis ou de programmeurs
ouais c'est l'une des grosses tensions
depuis Snowden  c'est quoi les états-unis qu'est-ce que la
Silicon Valley et je veux dire la Silicon Valley
en Californie mais vous savez plus largement
quelle est leur relation avec le
gouvernement des services de renseignement de la NSA et de la CIA
en général parce qu'il y a d'un côté
une volonté
de rejeter
un petit nombre de personnes qui sont  disant que
nous devons travailler sur les problèmes de sécurité nationale,
mais au niveau du clavier,
il y a encore beaucoup d'antagonisme et
j'imagine que c'est encore une fois une question
de confiance,
mais quand vous demandez ce que je pense
de cette situation enneigée, c'est comme si
les cheveux sur ma nuque
remontent juste parce que la
logique interne n'a pas de sens pour
moi et n'a toujours pas l'
air d'être autre chose qu'une
opération de renseignement et peut-être que je suis trop
conspirateur euh
vous dénoncez
comme Chelsea Manning
comme Snowden l'
Amérique est exclusivement américaine
non, je pense que
c'est l'une des grandes conversations en
Amérique sur vous connaissez les valeurs fondatrices
en ce moment et je pense que les idées de
liberté sont bonnes,
mais la façon dont vous
dénoncez compte aussi
le contexte
de
la sécurité
mais si vous divulguez des documents
avec l'idée que vous défendez
la liberté
et
l'expression de valeurs qui sont à votre
avis constitutionnelles,
je ne sais pas comment vous décidez d'aller dans un
endroit
où ce n'est pas le cas  Je peux dire ce que tu veux en toute sécurité
dans
un endroit comme la Russie,
peut-être cette question de sécurité physique,
je ne le fais pas, je ne le fais pas, il ne semble pas que ce soit
la surveillance d'At T et d'autres
centres de données aux États-
Unis.  citoyens ouais donc utiliser une
entreprise de télécommunications américaine ouais ouais donc je veux dire ouais donc utiliser
des nœuds d'entreprises de télécommunications américaines pour capturer
des données nationales, ce qui est interdit
c'est interdit ouais d'accord
[Musique]
réfugiés
non, je
ne le fais pas, je ne pense pas
comme ça  Je pense que
cela serait d'aller voir certains des
législateurs du Congrès, potentiellement
une Jane Harmon, quelqu'un comme ça, ainsi que
leur comité et leur personnel qui travaillent
au sein du comité du renseignement
et et
si vous êtes prêt à mettre en danger,
vous connaissez aussi les secrets nationaux.  bien sûr,
parce que la dénonciation a un coût,
je veux dire, il y a un
compromis,
mais ce n'est pas le cas, je n'arrive toujours pas à
comprendre, aller dans un pays comme la
Russie, l'Allemagne, peut-être aller
voir un membre du congrès et
travailler avec le  le comité est bien
plus pour moi, la logique interne est plus
cohérente,
l'effet serait toujours le même
parce que même si vous divulguiez les
informations,
mais pour trouver refuge
dans la Russie de Poutine, je ne peux pas, je n'arrive pas à
comprendre  à ce
sujet,
je suis très américain
devant,
je pense presque qu'il faut l'examiner en
deux volets différents, le secteur privé
et le gouvernement, et déterminer
où pouvez-vous faire des progrès plus rapides.
J'aimerais penser qu'en
parallèle, vous pouvez faire valoir vos arguments.  car
du point de vue commercial, vous êtes
véritablement propriétaire de vos propres données et
elles ont alors une valeur économique, de sorte que dans
10 ans, dans 15 ans,
lorsque nous aurons moins d'heures disponibles pour
travailler,
qu'il s'agisse de vendre nos données ou que
nos données vous soient échangées  Je sais que pour
les annonceurs ou quoi que ce soit, il y a
une certaine valeur économique, c'est qu'une solution
au revenu de base est un peu
dystopique, mais c'est
aussi que vous savez que la tendance
du côté du gouvernement est
les niveaux de
cryptage disponibles aujourd'hui et à
venir.
Quant
à l'informatique quantique, ils
sont fascinants à cet égard car
il y a deux façons de procéder et donc lorsque
je projette du côté gouvernemental de l'
individu par rapport à l'État,
il y a à la fois la capacité de percer
n'importe quel secret partout,
je veux dire quelle époque cela serait  voir
être fascinant incroyablement déstabilisé
[Musique]
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
j'imagine que les services de renseignement de
tous les pays essaient de casser tous les
codes partout
mais je ne le fais pas, vraiment, je veux dire, je suis un tu
sais je  Je ne sais pas,
mais qu'en est-il du côté quantique, encore une fois, en
utilisant mon genre de cerveau prévoyant,
il y a bien sûr l'idée qu'avec l'
informatique quantique,
toutes les données que les chinois ont
volées peuvent soudainement être déverrouillées, c'est
une chose et c'est une chose.
une sacrée grosse menace euh parce que
du coup avec l'IA tu peux modéliser une société
et la manipuler mais
mais mais je le ferai mais je vais juste je vais juste dire
vite
[Musique]
oh je veux dire c'est un peu comme le  chose qui
vous donne envie de jouer de la musique mais en
fin de compte, c'est l'intention du
gouvernement, n'est-ce pas, cela compte absolument
et de la même manière pour moi, si
les français volent mes données ou si
les chinois sont à un certain niveau, cela n'a pas d'
importance,
car vous êtes  perdre la propriété de
vos informations,
mais en fin de compte,
je m'inquiète moins
de ce premier que de ce dernier, le
droit
national et l'objectif stratégique
sont différents,
l'utilisation et la militarisation des
informations, en particulier celles
qui sont volées, qu'il s'agisse de modéliser
votre
courrier électronique pour une future attaque de chasse sous-marine,
que ce soit  c'est la possibilité de
dupliquer ou de reproduire votre existence en ligne
pendant une guerre,
je ne m'inquiète pas si la France me fait ça,
je m'inquiète pour la Russie, excusez-moi, la Russie
ouais, mais aussi la Chine,
donc
le contexte est tout pour moi
et cela ne prend rien  loin
d'un
regard lucide sur
l'histoire,
mais en regardant où nous en sommes maintenant et
ce qui se passe dans le futur, je ne peux pas, je
ne peux pas voir d'équivalence entre les deux,
même lorsqu'il s'agit de quelque chose d'aussi fondamental
que la militarisation des données, par
exemple, imaginez  évoquant
[Musique]
hmm
donc si je comprends bien c'est l'
idée que je peux parler lentement si tu veux bien
si c'est
vrai
je comprends l'idée que
tous ces outils
que la communauté du renseignement aux
États-Unis, en particulier l'armée d'ailleurs, a
assemblés peuvent  tout aussi facilement être utilisé
entre les mains d'un président maléfique
contre ses propres citoyens, tout comme
un régime autoritaire comme la Chine, c'est
absolument quelque chose qui m'inquiéterait
parce que
oui, absolument parce que ce sont des
outils très puissants et que nous venons de
traverser
une présidence extrêmement inquiétante
avec le président Trump
et il pourrait se présenter à nouveau, il pourrait gagner à nouveau
et à quoi ressemblera cette période de temps,
donc cette question de nouveau sur
la capacité de considérer le rôle de l'
individu dans cette société
qui est élevée avec
des données se pose à nouveau.  swade
plus tôt
a des implications
en 2023, pendant la période précédant les
élections, en 2024, pendant les élections elles-mêmes,
je pense que chaque citoyen occidental, que ce soit
en France, en Allemagne ou
aux États-Unis,
doit être constamment conscient de ce
que nous  Nous utilisons aujourd'hui une technologie
qui peut être utilisée dans l'intérêt public, ce
qui crée toujours une tension qui
peut certainement être exercée contre vous en un simple clic,
et donc constitutionnel à ce
niveau fondamental,
c'est quelque chose qui n'est plus abstrait,
c'est réel
et
et  il est important d'essayer de réfléchir aux moyens d'amener les
gens à s'en soucier
car
cette question est très complexe.
[Musique]
vous savez, la réponse que je viens de donner est en
partie juste, vous connaissez l'
idée que nous avons.  Nous vivons dans des sociétés
où
nous savons tout de nous et pourtant
parfois rien de bien et où nous avons l'impression de
ne pas avoir de voix ou d'action
et d'imaginer,
euh, en Amérique dans
15 ans,
où beaucoup
moins d'Américains ont des emplois qu'ils
trouvent significatifs et où il y en a
plus.
la résistance et l'organisation d'extrême
droite par des politiciens mais aussi par d'autres
personnes qui sont
très intéressées par
la création du chaos, dans un sens presque anarchique,
et je n'impute même rien aux
Russes, il n'y a pas de Russes dans ce
livre,
c'est une question intérieure
et et  donc
l'idée
que vous pouvez vous retrouver dans un monde dans
lequel
tout ce que vous ressentiez fonctionnait à merveille
n'est soudainement pas le cas, car il y a eu un
changement de paradigme économique, politique et
culturel, c'est ce qui nous a motivé à
écrire ce livre, car
nous nous dirigeons tête baissée vers une ère dans
laquelle  l'IA et la robotique vont
transformer tous les aspects de la société,
cela va transformer
les choses fondamentales qui nous donnent notre
identité, les emplois que nous
faisons, cela va tout changer, depuis
la façon dont les politiciens, dans un sens, sont capables de
nous envoyer des messages, mais aussi de contrôler leurs
populations
avec  ces mêmes technologies
et personne ne veut en parler ce
n'est pas une discussion populaire c'est
comme une
ligne de pensée vraiment dépressive euh euh tu sais j'aimerai souvent
finir un café avec quelqu'un nous nous
regardons tous les deux nous'  Nous sommes
comme Dieu
mais c'est pourquoi nous écrivons
correctement, nous essayons de permettre aux gens de
comprendre les choses que nous voulons éviter,
c'était vrai avec Flood Phantom, c'est
vrai avec le contrôle,
nous devons comprendre et penser à l'
impensable,
ce que
nous pourrions manquer à propos du  monde maintenant
parce que c'est inconfortable, nous ne voulons pas
y penser et pour moi, un roman est un
moyen idéal de le faire,
vous pouvez toujours vous divertir et avoir en quelque sorte
cette conscience accrue et je
pense que c'est crucial de pouvoir
le faire dans  d'une manière accessible à
tous, n'importe qui peut lire un livre, vous
n'avez même pas besoin de l'acheter,
allez à la bibliothèque,
j'espère qu'il comprendra ces
questions très complexes sur la technologie d'
un point de vue humain, vous savez,
cet agent du FBI et pas seulement elle  mais sa
famille, je veux dire, c'est un roman qui
parle d'un agent du FBI chassant son ennemi terroriste,
son partenaire robot,
mais
aussi
sa relation avec son mari
et sa fille et son mari était un
avocat qui est allé dans les universités américaines de l'Ivy League,
la grande Nicole
ne l'a jamais fait.  quelque chose qui ne va pas dans sa vie,
un bon gars,
quelqu'un qui, aux États-Unis, croit que le
système
leur doit quelque chose
et à cause d'un algorithme dans son cabinet d'avocats,
son emploi très bien rémunéré lui a été
retiré
et cela a de profondes implications pour
notre héros, car elle n'est pas seulement
devenue
la  seul soutien de famille le seul revenu de
leur foyer
mais aussi la nature même de ce qu'elle
doit faire pour sauver Washington
implique de travailler avec un robot que son
mari méprise elle déteste il déteste le
fait qu'elle travaille avec la
technologie même qui le rend malheureux et
qui le ruine
la société et cette contradiction est pour moi
fascinante
et c'est une expérience vraiment humaine, c'est
vrai, c'est un genre d'histoire très différent
de celui du fantôme de Leflot
pour cette raison, il s'agit avant tout d'
entrer dans la tête des gens qui
vivent dans cette Amérique du futur,
l'apprentissage automatique
[Musique]
[Musique] L'
inégalité du mode de vie américain est
un problème structurel en Amérique qui
pourrait ruiner le pays dans les 20 à
30 prochaines années.
Notre incapacité à éduquer nos jeunes
pour prendre soin de nos malades
et moi et moi avons l'air, euh,
vous savez, pessimiste ici, mais  nous avons
très peu de progrès significatifs
pour résoudre ces problèmes de manière significative
et cela ne veut même pas parler de la violence armée,
mais simplement de regarder l'éducation et
les soins de santé,
vous savez, créant des opportunités économiques
dans un monde si l'Amérique, nous avons parlé plus tôt
de ce genre de trois
Si vous voulez être l'endroit où
vous voulez que les gens les plus intelligents viennent,
il serait
judicieux d'essayer d'être l'endroit où
vous avez certains des plus instruits
et des plus intelligents au sens large
du monde.
Je ne sous-traite pas correctement l'innovation
et il y a très peu d'intérêt
politique à le faire.
C'est extrêmement décourageant pour quelqu'un
qui a des enfants et qui regarde l'avenir.
Je me pose constamment cette question :
le monde va-t-il être pire, y
a-t-il une chance qu'il puisse être meilleur ?  et
encore une fois, cela ne prend même pas en compte
le climat,
euh, le réchauffement climatique
et donc une
partie de l'écriture d'une histoire et du fait de passer, vous
savez, deux ans à penser à ces pensées dystopiques qui vivent dans
ma tête, cet appartement dans lequel
vit Laura Keegan
consiste à comprendre ce
paradigme
de la façon dont  nous ne sommes
tout simplement
pas à la hauteur de l'occasion où nous savons
ce que nous devons faire et personne ne veut
permettre de grandes inégalités économiques en
Amérique et je ne suis pas du tout socialiste,
je suis un capitaliste, bien sûr, euh,
mais permettre de telles inégalités
inégalité béante,
euh, je ne suis pas un
capitaliste socialiste, vous connaissez
bien
la capacité
de permettre une richesse aussi extrême
et c'est encore une fois un thème du livre
pour
permettre à un dirigeant qui dirige une
société de plusieurs milliards de dollars de gagner des
centaines de fois plus.  de leur
employé, cela n'a aucun sens et
j'ai passé une grande partie de ma carrière de
journaliste financier à
interviewer des dirigeants, à interviewer
des employés couvrant les
plus grandes faillites, certains d'entre eux en
Amérique,
à voir la montée de la première
économie Internet et son krach,
à voir la compagnie aérienne.  krach de l'industrie après le
11 septembre
voir le crash de second.com j'ai couvert
tout ça les faillites les
industries automobiles j'ai vu le
carnage économique qui peut se produire
et nous ne parvenons toujours pas à comprendre
comment rendre notre société plus résiliente,
n'est-ce pas
et en tant que spécialiste de la
défense qui travaille très sérieusement sur ces questions et autour de ces
questions,
je pense toujours que nous ne prêtons pas suffisamment
attention
à ces questions plus douces,
il est si important de considérer le
dynamisme national non seulement en termes d'ordre
de bataille,
de force  de l'armée mais comment
allons-nous
prendre soin de certains des plus faibles ou de
ceux qui ne peuvent pas s'en empêcher, il n'y
a pas d'avenir sans cela
et cela encore peut être pessimiste et
et moi et moi encore, je suis un fier américain
mais je'  Je suis incroyablement découragé
par la situation dans laquelle nous nous trouvons en
France,
euh,
c'est cet aspect de l'éducation, n'est-ce pas,
sommes-nous à un point où les gens ne
comprennent pas ce qui se passe, ce qui leur est
fait, n'est-ce pas, euh,
je pense que
c'est extrêmement, cela devient de plus en plus
facile pour  les dirigeants politiques
profitent de l'inattention et du
manque de pensée critique des gens, ce
n'est pas une question d'
intelligence innée, comme si l'idiocratie
suppose littéralement une baisse du QI,
mais nous assistons à une militarisation de
l'inattention, ce qui est bizarre à
dire,
mais incroyablement
destructeur
si
les gens ne sont pas capables de réfléchir de manière critique
à tout, qu'il s'agisse de savoir
si une nouvelle politique est introduite
pour profiter d'eux, mais on leur
dit que c'est dans leur intérêt que l'
abrogation d'Obamacare est l'un de nos
avantages en matière de soins de santé les plus réussis dans le
pays et qui a été offert
en  une manière sans précédent pour plus d'
américains que jamais auparavant
et cela a été attaqué comme si c'était
l'une des choses les plus destructrices qui
auraient pu être faites au pays,
rien ne pourrait être plus éloigné de la vérité,
une des expériences vraiment intéressantes
pendant Covid  et cela se rapporte
au thème du contrôle parce que nous parlons
du revenu de base, de l'
idée que dans un monde où il y a moins de travail,
qu'allons-nous faire pour subvenir à
nos besoins fondamentaux si ce n'est une qualité de vie
qui a du sens
pendant la pandémie aux États-Unis
Je pense qu'en France, il y a eu un
soutien incroyable du gouvernement en termes
d'argent liquide, les gens ont littéralement déposé de l'argent liquide
sur leurs comptes bancaires,
ce qui était en fait un prototype de ce que
notre avenir pourrait nous réserver,
mais la conversation à ce sujet n'était pas tournée vers
l'avenir.  était
très enfermé dans la politique du
moment
et s'il existe un moyen viable d'instaurer un
revenu de base, nous devons le découvrir
si cela est possible,
mais le problème est l'incapacité de penser
de manière critique et d'observer ce qui se passe,
que ce soit un compromis équitable ou non.  ce n'est pas vrai,
cela vaut-il la peine d'émettre de la dette, cela
vaut-il le risque inflationniste, tous les
facteurs politiques et politiques traditionnels,
il est très difficile d'avoir ces
conversations au niveau national, regardez
comment les informations par câble sont diffusées aux États-Unis,
c'est une question de réponse émotionnelle plus que de
développement analytique.
j'ai du mal à regarder
je ne le fais pas j'essaie de ne pas le faire j'ai encore passé
toute ma carrière de journaliste avec la télé allumée
à côté de moi pendant 10 à 12 heures par jour
j'en ai eu assez mais le fait est que nous sommes
à un point où  ce n'est pas utile pour
penser, même sur les réseaux sociaux, j'ai une
relation amour-haine avec Twitter,
ce qui est une merveilleuse façon de se connecter avec
les gens
pour savoir des choses qui autrement n'auraient peut-être pas
traversé mon tableau arrière, mais trop
souvent, l'algorithme rétrécit ma
vision du monde plutôt que  cela ouvre
trop souvent ma capacité à me concentrer
et à penser le genre de pensées que je
veux mettre dans un livre qui semble vraiment
nouveau qui semble nouveau
qu'une fois de plus tout le monde regarde ici, je
veux y regarder, les
médias sociaux détruisent que
je suis tellement en conflit  à propos de cela et de l'
avenir dont nous parlons et contrôlons
en fin de compte une expression de ce
sentiment intérieur
d'essayer vraiment de comprendre que pour
chaque avantage technologique potentiel, il y
a un coût.
L'une des choses que nous espérons est que les
gens de la
Silicon Valley et de la
la communauté technologique peut utiliser le livre
pour mieux comprendre les conséquences
de ce type d'
inventions qui ont une immense
valeur marchande et qui rendent les gens riches avec des stock-
options ou
autre,
mais peut-être que ce n'est pas la bonne chose à faire pour l'
Amérique.
[Musique]
eh bien
je suis  C'est un domaine dans lequel
j'ai plus d'espoir
parce que nous avons aux États-Unis au moins
une conversation plus sophistiquée sur
la façon de développer
et de faire avancer de bonnes idées. La plupart des gens qui
travaillent
dans l'armée américaine vivent et
vivent avec PowerPoint.
c'est vrai, c'est un
moyen très très inefficace de communiquer
des idées.
Vous savez, vous pouvez trouver
des exemples en ligne de certains des graphiques les plus
complexes et les plus absurdes qui existent et qui ne
servent en fait à personne et
combien d'heures pourraient être économisées et mieux
dépensées à former comment  beaucoup d'argent
pourrait être économisé
si
vous interdisiez essentiellement PowerPoint comme
moyen de diriger une armée moderne comme les États-Unis.
Une journée sans PowerPoint serait
en fait une invitation créative fascinante,
mais cela
ne reflète pas le problème du manque de créativité
dans les rangs, car il y a
littéralement  un nombre illimité de
personnes intelligentes qui essaient de faire le travail, l'
une des plus grandes préoccupations à l'heure actuelle
avec l'IA et la robotique est ce qu'on appelle le
théâtre de l'innovation,
l'idée selon laquelle vous pouvez investir 10 millions de
dollars, 20 millions de dollars dans une idée
ou un concept, une petite entreprise
et
cochez une case, vous pouvez faire une
présentation PowerPoint qui dit que nous
investissons dans l'IA
même s'il n'y a jamais l'intention de
la déployer à grande échelle,
en particulier au sein d'une force aussi grande que
la nôtre,
cela représente un risque profond
si vous
effectuez ce genre de théâtre  sans
intention réelle de transformation, il
est si difficile de transformer les grandes organisations. Les
personnes qui
investissent leur carrière dans des
cellules d'innovation ont
pour la plupart
tendance à avoir des carrières plus courtes.
Les personnes qui souhaitent avoir une carrière longue
n'ont pas autant d'
opportunités de sortir d'un secteur.  chemin assez
prescrit
ouais
mon espoir cependant et c'est quelque chose
que vous avez revu c'est là que j'ai ce
regard je veux dire j'aime bien je dis que je suis j'aime
être optimiste mais j'ai beaucoup
de pessimisme en moi  et
c'est pourtant un domaine parce que je vois
de plus en plus d'officiers supérieurs
qui sont en passe de devenir
généraux, même certains des
généraux récents que nous avons eu
qui ont
été capables
de plaider en faveur
de ce type de travail et de protéger
les gens dans leur carrière.  pour les laisser continuer
à avancer, car ce n'est même pas souvent ce que
vous faites dans votre travail donné.
Si vous êtes le plus haut dirigeant,
il s'agit de trouver comment protéger les
personnes qui ont d'autres bonnes idées qui peuvent
faire partie de votre héritage.  L'un
des tests les plus importants en ce moment aux
États-Unis est la réforme du
corps des marines des États-Unis. Le
corps des marines des États-Unis
abandonne son engagement envers les chars. Le
char M1.
L'ethnosync.  c'est
la bonne chose que j'ai vue depuis longtemps
et c'est un processus qui a pris du temps
depuis l'ancien commandant
commandant burger et maintenant excusez-moi euh
plus et maintenant burger
cela pose des
risques politiques incroyables pour le
corps des marines
parce que les forces au sein de la
communauté du corps des marines à la retraite  vous vous
opposez à cela en disant que vous
désinfectez, vous enlevez les griffes pour
ainsi dire,
euh vous rendez le corps des marines
subordonné à la marine encore plus qu'il ne l'
est peut-être déjà, cela
va les rendre
incapables de combattre la Chine et
Pourtant, pour moi, c'est l'une des transformations bureaucratiques les plus
réussies
avec
les racines d'une bonne idée
de tout réenvisager fondamentalement,
depuis le type de fusil qu'un corps de marine
porte
jusqu'à
la façon dont les
petits groupes de soldats sur terre
qui appartiennent aux forces conventionnelles et non aux
forces  les forces spéciales
peuvent avoir un impact stratégique,
ce qui n'a pas fait partie de la
conversation traditionnelle
sur ce qu'il faut faire avec les forces terrestres dans l'
armée américaine, mais maintenant nous avons cela
et c'est de là que vient une partie de cet optimisme
parce que
le personnel s'efforce d'influencer  ces changements,
l'adhésion, la conviction du
dialogue tribal qui doit avoir lieu
au sein de ces différentes communautés
parce que les gens donnent des choses
qui leur sont chères, en particulier l'aviation,
c'est vraiment difficile à faire,
mais dans cette notion de transformation,
cette notion de
briser la bureaucratie
pour  faire ce qu'il faut,
c'est vraiment quelque chose à surveiller
s'il échoue, s'il est
abrogé, cela sera
extrêmement troublant
et de très mauvais augure pour les
transformations futures qui vont venir
et qui seront nécessaires depuis l'adoption de
tout, des avions robotisés à la
prochaine génération de  les chars sans pilote
l'une des plus grandes
tendances technologiques que nous allons voir est la
miniaturisation avec la robotique et bien
sûr l'utilisation croissante de logiciels
dans la guerre et ce que je pense est vraiment
très difficile pour  aux États-Unis,
dans nos relations industrielles de défense, le
logiciel n'a pas de
code postal, ce qui signifie qu'il n'y a pas de
membre du Congrès ou de législateur qui puisse posséder un
programme de la même manière
si vous construisez
un avion de combat
dans mon district,
je suis un défenseur du maintien  ce
programme,
si vous construisez un algorithme de ciblage ou un
algorithme de vol
à Pittsburgh qui ne fait pas partie
de l'establishment politique et est
beaucoup plus difficile à défendre et à voir à travers,
c'est le système que nous avons, donc je suis très
conscient de celui de cette transformation
de la même manière
avec l'idée que la robotique va
permettre de plus en plus de miniaturisation,
nous n'achèterons plus d'
avions de combat pour 200 millions de dollars,
nous allons acheter des avions d'un million de
dollars qui ont de profondes
implications économiques pour les
grandes sociétés cotées en bourse qui ne le font pas.  Je ne
veux pas que ceux qui ne soient pas équipés pour ce
monde et même nos plus petites
entreprises innovantes, dont un
nombre croissant veulent travailler avec
le ministère de la Défense, il est difficile pour
elles
d'avoir la chance de
participer parce que tout est tellement
verrouillé
c'est
[Musique]
je pense à euh,
cette question du besoin d'être
capable de penser sans penser est vraiment
vitale pour l'analyse afin de trouver des moyens de
traiter
ce que vous avez absorbé
d'une manière ce n'est pas passive mais  comme la
façon dont j'agis, la façon dont j'y
accède
est de trouver une activité physique à laquelle je
ne peux pas penser je fais du vélo je suis un grand
cycliste donc je ferai du vélo de montagne
tu es sur un vélo de montagne tu ne peux pas
penser  à propos de la politique de défense, vous essayez de
ne pas heurter un arbre, vous essayez d'
éviter n'importe quel journal,
mais presque à chaque fois que je
prends le temps de faire un tour,
j'ai des idées que je n'avais pas avant
et parce que comme moi  je disais qu'avec les
médias sociaux, nous sommes bombardés dans mon
cerveau, je regarde constamment, je regarde
l'autocollant sur ton ordinateur et je
pense que c'est quelque chose d'inspirant,
je sens et je vois constamment,
je regarde une boîte de céréales et je  Je suis et je
lis bien, c'est comme ça que mon
cerveau fonctionne, donc je prends constamment
les choses en compte et je dois donc trouver le temps de
les traiter
et vous savez, je ne suis pas un écrivain qui peut
rester assis à un bureau pendant huit heures.  heures par jour, je
peux écrire 90 minutes à la fois très
attentivement,
vous savez, si j'écris dans un café, les gens
me regardent bizarrement parce que je suis
au clavier
et cela fait partie pour moi de
comprendre comment obtenir de bonnes idées,
comme où  est-ce qu'une bonne idée vient de
vous savez
et c'est comme ça que j'ai
compris qu'il a fallu beaucoup de temps pour l'
apprécier parce qu'en tant que journaliste,
vous êtes enfermé dans un fauteuil, vous êtes enfermé
dans un cycle d'information, vous avez une date limite,
que ce soit  c'est une impression de journal,
que ce soit dans un fil d'information financier
en temps réel,
je me suis maintenant permis de travailler d'une manière
où les délais sont plus longs
et cela m'a donné plus de temps pour
réfléchir et c'était l'une des meilleures
décisions, je pense  J'ai fait pour créer cet
espace
car cela permet également plus d'
introspection sur ce qui me manque
et travailler avec un partenaire comme
Peter Singer
est également un contrôle utile sur
cette notion d'
où sont mes préjugés, qu'est-ce qui me
manque et avoir quelqu'un qui est  plus intelligent
que vous avec qui vous travaillez est l'une des
qualités les plus importantes chez un coéquipier,
être capable d'avoir une
conversation honnête et confiante où vous
savez et nous avons de la chance d'avoir une
amitié autant qu'une
relation intellectuelle qui n'est pas toujours la bonne.  Dans le
cas de l'écriture en équipe, souvent,
les gens n'ont pas cela,
mais il y a un niveau de confiance fondamental
qui se reflète également dans la façon dont nous écrivons. Vous
savez, lorsque vous lisez euh la fleur fantôme, lorsque vous
lisez le contrôle, vous ne pouvez pas dire qui
a écrit quelles sections,
car quand  nous écrivons, nous donnons à l'autre
personne notre section peut être un
chapitre entier, cela peut être une page
et l'autre personne a le droit de la
détruire
complètement
et c'est un grand pas en avant que beaucoup d'écrivains
ne peuvent tout simplement pas faire, il y a trop d'
ego, là aussi  beaucoup d'investissement dans
les mots,
je pense qu'une des choses, avoir été
journaliste, avoir
été quelqu'un qui écrivait, a été
constamment sauvage
et détruit par mes éditeurs pour le rendre
meilleur,
m'a permis de comprendre presque une notion
de confiance dans le processus,
euh, de savoir que comme moi  en fait, je n'ai peut-
être pas la meilleure idée de la meilleure façon d'
exprimer quelque chose
et je pense que c'est l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles notre partenariat créatif fonctionne si
bien et pourquoi les livres se révèlent,
pourquoi ils pourquoi ils fonctionnent
[Musique]
euh
si nous pouvons parler de n'importe quoi
Je pense que j'essaierais probablement
de comprendre
les
forces et les thèmes plus larges qui sont à l'œuvre
dans la société civile
et quels sont les leviers
que nous, en tant qu'individus ou ensemble,
pouvons actionner pour les changer, quelle est la
notion de volonté publique et c'est cela
une question
non seulement de pure descendance, mais
la façon dont la technologie nous permet de
communiquer les uns avec les autres
est incroyablement intéressante pour ses
opportunités, elle nous permet de créer un
réseau pour flashmob avec n'importe quoi,
mais il y a aussi un côté plus sombre à cela
auquel je pense  il y a beaucoup de choses
qui peuvent être transformées en armes et cette
idée de savoir
si nous avons un domaine aérien, un
domaine terrestre, un domaine spatial, un domaine c,
est-il temps pour le
cyber, bien sûr, est-il
temps pour un sixième domaine, une
conversation sur cette notion de
domaine humain a  domaine cognitif,
c'est l'une des choses auxquelles je préfère
penser et
elle est
étroitement liée à la question du
déclin politique du progrès technologique
et à la nature changeante de la guerre
elle-même.
Être capable de
réussir militairement ou stratégiquement
sans
jamais déployer de soldat
est un défi.  aspect vraiment fascinant
du conflit au 21ème siècle
exactement
euh
[Musique]
William Gibson qui est un écrivain de science-fiction,
qui est vraiment quelqu'un
qui a
donné naissance à la montée de ce que nous appelions
le mouvement cyberpunk et qui est passé
à d'autres types de  concepts dans ses
écrits
euh et je le considérerais comme un
philosophe même s'il ne l'est pas, vous savez, dans le
sens pas d'une académie nationale, c'est
quelqu'un qui avait une
manière d'écrire très réaliste et réaliste
qui m'a aidé quand j'étais très jeune
quand je lisais  je comprends
cet aspect de la technologie,
que peut-être que ce n'est pas tout ce qu'elle est
censée être,
c'est un peu comme dans les années 1980, quand j'ai
grandi, quand tu voyais des représentations du
futur, tout était propre, c'est vrai,
tu avais beaucoup d'
ordinateurs blancs, des meubles blancs  rien n'a
jamais été sale dans un roman de William Gibson,
tout est sale et graveleux et
crasseux,
je pense que c'est
vraiment un aspect essentiel de la façon dont je
pense à l'avenir,
euh en termes de
philosophe politique pur,
j'essaie de  mieux comprendre les
lois des conflits armés que vous connaissez à partir d'un
cadre éthique en lisant des
textes historiques et traditionnels,
comme
Thomas d'Aquin, des choses comme ça et je fais
cela avec des profanes avec une
perspective novice n'ayant pas étudié cela de
manière approfondie,
mais en pensant aux conflits futurs,
c'est incroyablement  important, je pense qu'il faut
regarder de manière fondamentale avec quoi nous établissons
les lois des conflits armés
pour une perspective finale
sur une source d'inspiration philosophique.
J'essaie de penser à un autre écrivain
et je parlerai probablement
à nouveau
de la guerre cognitive,
elle pourrait être le général cinq étoiles du  Le
cadre de la guerre future,
à droite,
Ray Bradbury est un écrivain américain de science-
fiction qui, comme William
Gibson, adopte presque une approche philosophique
pour penser non seulement à l'avenir,
car toutes ses histoires ne traitaient pas du fait qu'il traitait
parfois de l'étrange et de l'abstrait,
mais fondamentalement jamais.  perdre de vue
l'expérience humaine
dans
des réalités alternatives que nous pouvons avoir ou
non
mais qui reflètent fondamentalement le monde
dans lequel nous sommes, donc Fahrenheit 451 est un
roman et j'ai récemment regardé une
version américaine de celui-ci au cinéma
euh avec Michael B Jordan qui  est vraiment
bien
mais alors j'ai relu le roman
et et fondamentalement ce qui était
intéressant dans ce livre
c'était
Montag le pompier l'homme dont le métier
est de brûler des livres bien sûr il
les cache
mais ses relations avec sa femme
sont très perturbantes
mais très  pertinent pour comprendre le
monde,
deuxièmement, son mentor émergent qui est l'un
des dissidents
des
bibliothécaires en quelque sorte, qui
travaille vraiment à préserver l'écrit
dans les derniers instants de cet
aspect de l'humanité
et c'est une méditation très puissante sur
ce que signifie  partager des connaissances pour être
humains ensemble parce que le monde dans lequel
vit Montag est complètement déshumanisé,
ce n'est rien de plus que
des entrées neurologiques provenant d'écrans, la notion de
réflexion que propose le livre et que Ray
Bradbury pose au lecteur pour qu'il
comprenne est l'une des
pierres angulaires de  du droit de la communauté,
pas seulement de la civilisation, mais
les livres communautaires sont la façon dont nous nous comprenons, ce
qui me parle. Je ne pense pas y
avoir pensé aussi profondément quand j'étais
jeune, j'ai juste aimé lire du
vin de pissenlit ou des chroniques martiennes ou autre, mais au fur et à mesure que
je passe  plus de temps à écrire, c'est
incroyablement important,
en particulier cette histoire
est
ouais, ma femme, euh, je plaisante en disant que Peter est ma
femme de travail, ce qui signifie que vous savez, nous passons
tellement de temps émotionnellement, c'est un bon
arbre et mentalement ensemble parce que
même si nous vivons dans des villes différentes,
nous sommes  jamais loin l'un de l'autre c'est
assez drôle euh
mais je pense qu'en fait
nous avons tous les deux appris à
mieux nous connaître grâce au travail et en fait
pendant la convoitise c'était vraiment intéressant
nous sommes arrivés tous les deux, je pense que nous comptons
de plus en plus l'un sur l'autre en tant qu'amis  nous
avions même travaillé sur deux romans
et c'est une chose remarquable,
je veux dire, c'est une chose profonde, c'est une
chose personnelle
mais je crois que c'est vraiment vraiment
merveilleux d'avoir ce niveau d'
amitié intellectuellement, nos cerveaux sont
certainement différents, j'ai un très court
j'arrive à mieux comprendre mon esprit
à mesure que je travaille et ma capacité d'attention est
courte
donc nous aurons une conversation,
surtout s'il s'agit d'une conversation de planification
et je veux passer à la
chose la plus intéressante dans laquelle je veux
aborder directement  et c'est comme si non, nous sommes
en train de traiter ici et et c'est l'un de
mes gros angles morts, c'est le processus, je suis
très instinctif, je
vois quelque chose
qui m'intrigue, je veux le trouver, choisissez-le,
comprenez-le,
intégrez-le à quelque chose d'autre.
J'ai dû apprendre à quel point c'est un
handicap, en particulier dans les grands
projets qui prennent des années, vous ne pouvez pas faire
ces choses de manière impulsive ou
instinctive, il y a
un processus logistique pour
eux
et c'est quelque chose parce que mon
co-scénariste Peter a eu plus d'expérience.
en écrivant des livres de non-fiction, il a écrit un
doctorat,
euh, il a un processus merveilleux et il y a un
autre
aspect de sa personnalité qui est tout simplement
merveilleux et qui est l'un de mes autres
angles morts. Je ne suis pas très bon en
plaidoyer ou en promotion, n'est-ce pas, je veux dire,
j'aime parler et avoir  conversations, je
pourrais faire ça, vous le savez toute la nuit,
mais quand il s'agit de vraiment
comprendre ce que signifie être un
écrivain,
vous devez être très avisé
sur la façon dont vous comprenez le marché,
comprendre comment vous vous y situez
et cela a été très utile et  c'est l'
une des choses les plus fortes
qu'il apporte à cette
relation
parce que je ne suis tout simplement pas aussi bon dans ce domaine, je
m'améliore mais je travaille, je dois y travailler
activement
intellectuellement,
elle
[Musique]
je n'ai pas beaucoup de  amis
[Rires]
j'ai
travaillé à Washington DC
où tout le monde est extrêmement dans le genre
de monde politique bien instruit très
engagé
euh
je vis maintenant j'habite à Boston dans
une communauté qui ne fait pas partie du
monde politique
et en fait  J'en suis venu à vraiment aimer
ça parce que je peux parler à quelqu'un de ce que
je fais et ils me regardent comme
si c'était un bon travail
et ce que cela vous oblige à faire et je
ne veux pas dire que de manière dénigrante,
c'est plutôt un  reflet de la façon dont le
monde au sens large comprend les choses dans lesquelles
beaucoup d'entre nous passent notre vie à essayer de s'améliorer
et cela oblige beaucoup de réflexion,
donc je n'ai pas vraiment
cette antipathie innée, vous savez, quand
quelqu'un ne se soucie pas de vous savez
la Chine et sa menace de guerre dans les
cinq prochaines années,
euh, à la place,
j'essaie presque de la comprendre davantage à partir de
ce qui est important pour eux parce que
c'est peut-être surtout un truc d'écrivain,
mais fondamentalement, lorsque vous essayez de
comprendre ce qui se passe dans le
futur,
vous savez que je  Je n'écris pas de livres sur moi
comme je ne veux pas, je ne veux pas
écrire un livre sur moi, n'est-ce pas, j'essaie
d'écrire un livre sur de vraies personnes
et, vous savez, tout le monde ne
sera pas obsédé par les choses.  je suis obsédé
par et donc pouvoir être
ouvert au niveau humain, je pense que cela fait
aussi partie de mon optimisme, c'est juste d'
essayer de rencontrer des gens là où ils sont
si vous avez conduit à Boston,
c'est facile de détester l'humanité
peut-être que Paris aussi
euh et  penser que nous sommes désespérés,
mais sérieusement, passer du
temps avec les gens pour vraiment les voir
là où ils sont,
je pense que l'une des meilleures choses que vous
puissiez faire
est de
dire que si vous voulez lire un livre sur l'
Amérique,
c'est  Je pense que l'un des plus
intéressants, c'est en fait une trilogie
de Don Winslow
qui
commence, j'efface le nom, elle vient de se
terminer avec le dernier livre intitulé The
Border,
il s'agit essentiellement de la montée de la
narcoéconomie
au Mexique, aux États-Unis
et après.  cela à travers un
personnage très spécifique et unique qui est
essentiellement un agent de la mort
euh c'est l'une des pièces les plus importantes
de la fiction américaine
contre trois romans peut-être 1200 pages ou
plus au total
le plus récemment la frontière
le pouvoir du chien est la première
la voiture  le cartel est le deuxième
et le troisième est la frontière il s'occupe
de tout, de
l'industrie pharmaceutique
à la corruption politique à la maison blanche
c'est une vraie saga ok non non il le
fait il le fait il le traite
il regarde pas seulement ça mais
tout, des entrepreneurs militaires privés
qui font du contre, c'est une
histoire complète et sa capacité à faire
des recherches et je pense qu'il a écrit à
ce stade 15 ou 16 romans donc c'est un
maître
donc je lirais le pouvoir du
cartel canin je lirais
la frontière
je  Je reviendrais à William Gibson que j'ai
mentionné plus tôt.
Je recommanderais à tout le monde de lire ses
livres plus anciens, mais il a un roman plus récent
appelé The Device
qui se déroule à nouveau aux États-Unis. Il
décrit un avenir très dystopique
dans lequel il y a plus d'automatisation,
bien sûr,
mais il traite  avec un
ensemble de problèmes vraiment intéressants qui proviennent en partie de
l'invention de
ce qu'on appelle le tunnel quantique, la
capacité de communiquer entre différentes
réalités et cela ressemble à de la science-
fiction
mais c'est plus que cela et c'est
vraiment une histoire sur l'avenir de l'Amérique
en particulier  la politique et le pouvoir que je
recommande vivement
et il a une suite à cela également
appelée agence
le troisième livre je pourrais dire
qui a eu une influence sur moi, je veux
dire, je lis tout le temps mais quand
j'étais très jeune
et j'y retournerai  ce dont nous avons parlé
plus tôt avec celui du premier, le
deuxième livre de Tom Clancy, Red Storm Rise,
ce n'est pas de la haute littérature mais j'ai lu ce
livre à 12 ans
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que mon
co-scénariste Peter Singer aussi, nous avons tous les deux eu la
même expérience  vraiment, pour la première
fois, je prenais un livre et je ne bougeais pas
jusqu'à ce que tu l'aies bien terminé et c'était
le genre d'enfant que j'étais comme si je ferais
ça
et quand nous avons écrit La Fleur Fantôme, j'ai
relu ce livre pour
m'inspirer, ce que nous aimons beaucoup  ce que j'ai fait,
c'était vraiment une sorte de moment alpha oméga
de retour à tu sais, je
plaisante parfois en disant que ce que je fais maintenant n'est pas très
différent de ce que je pensais que je
devrais faire à 15 ou 16 ans, tu
sais, lire et écrire, tu connais la
fiction  et et et
des choses comme ça
mais ces livres sont tous assez
différents
mais pour chacun,
Don Winslow est le genre d'écrivain que j'aspire
à être le même que William Gibson
qui, je pense, peut vraiment aborder
ces sujets complexes à merveille
et puis vous savez clancy pour juste  étant
la première graine qui a été plantée
pourquoi l'Amérique est-elle le plus beau
pays
ne l'est-elle plus pourquoi ne l'est-elle pas
oh euh
je pense que je disais notre incapacité
à prendre soin les uns des autres, je veux dire si je
pouvais le réduire à un niveau humain, pas de
politique  pas de politique,
nous arrêtons de prendre soin les uns des autres,
ce n'est pas une religion, ce n'est
pas une doctrine, c'est juste au niveau humain,
nos divisions sont
exploitées chaque jour à des fins économiques
pour des gains politiques et cela nuit à
notre capacité à prendre soin les uns des autres.
cela ressemble presque à un
message épiscopalien chrétien, mais nous devons
faire cela mieux et si et si vous deviez
penser à la résilience
si vous deviez penser à notre avenir comme
un endroit où les gens veulent vivre et
avoir des enfants
hmm
j'aimerais  J'ai eu un
aphorisme vraiment concis,
j'y pense beaucoup avec mes mes mes
filles,
je pense que je reviendrais à ce que je viens de
dire : prends soin des autres
quand tu es confronté à une
décision difficile, prends-tu soin de quelqu'un
d'autre ?
je
quand tu penses aux décisions que nous
prenons dans nos vies nous devons vivre avec
elles elles viennent à nous la nuit elles
envahissent nos esprits pendant la journée
il est important d'être capable de prendre
des décisions même quand nous devons en prendre
de mauvaises parce que parfois  nous le faisons, nous devons
vivre avec eux
et je pense que si vous pouvez revenir à un
principe comme celui-là
et encore une fois, je sais que cela semble ringard comme
vous diriez en anglais, mais je pense que
c'est une qualité humaine fondamentale
que nous pouvons'  Je n'ai pas peur,
surtout quand tant de
gens essaient de nous séparer ou de
nous amener à nous battre les uns contre les autres. Je pense que je
mettrais dans cette bouteille,
prends soin des autres
si je pense à la façon dont j'élève mes
filles.  je veux qu'ils soient aventureux
prendre des risques physiquement émotionnellement
intellectuellement mais savoir comment prendre
soin des autres et c'est difficile à
enseigner ce n'est pas facile ce n'est certainement pas
facile
août cool merci [
Applaudissements]
merced
[Musique]
toi